zum begräbnis reisen solle von
regierungsseite ist keiner gereist daher
heute hier im bundestag dieses gedenken
im anschluss dann nach einer kurzen
pause beginnt die generaldebatte nach
der vorstellung des entlastungspaket am
wochenende der erste größere
schlagabtausch zwischen regierung und
opposition es dürfte also spannend
werden zuerst aber hält bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas eine rede zur
würdigung von michael gorbatschow ich
denke wir schauen mal rein ins plenum
die reihen haben sich schon gefüllt es
sind schon viele da traditionell ist ja
sowohl bei der generaldebatte aber
sicherlich auch bei einem solchen
gedenken für gorbatschow das haus
gefüllt eigentlich müsste auch das ganze
kabinett dasein schon anwesend hier
sehen wir bereits friedrich merz ist
bereits anwesend und auch der
bundespräsident sitzt oben auf der
zuschauertribüne auch er ist heute
anwesend wir hören mal rein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen eröffnet
die sitzung
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir trauern um herren michael
sergejewitsch gorbatschow der am
dreißigsten august verstorben ist
präsident gorbatschow war ein mann des
friedens er veränderte die welt zum
besseren
er machte möglich was über jahrzehnte
undenkbar schien
den kalten krieg friedlich zu beenden
und die teilung unseres landes und
unseres kontinents zu überwinden
wir deutschen haben michael gorbatschow
viel zu verdanken
er hat die geschichte unseres landes und
das leben von millionen menschen
verändert
sein mut und seine haltung waren
entscheidend für die wiedererlangung
unserer staatlichen einheit diesen
einzigartigen und großen moment unserer
geschichte das werden wir nicht
vergessen
er war wegbereiter der wiedervereinigung
mit seinem unverhofften aufbruch in eine
neue politik hatte den menschen in der
ddr mut gemacht sich selbst zu
ermächtigen
glasnost und perestroika
warum sollte das nicht auch in der ddr
möglich sein
auch sein besuch in ost-berlin im
oktober
1989 zum vierzigsten starts jubiläum der
ddr trug dazu bei dass die deutschen in
der ddr gegen die sed diktatur
aufbegehrt
als frauen und männer
1989 in immer größerer zahl in plauen in
leipzig in ostberlin in dresden in
schwerin in magdeburg und an vielen
anderen orten in der ddr auf die straße
ging fragten sich viele werden wieder
panzer rollen
doch die sowjetischen soldaten blieben
in ihren kasernen
das ende der ddr und die deutsche
wiedervereinigung
erfolgten friedlich
die us amerikanische publizistin
applebaum schrieb ich zitiere
gorbatschows radikalste handlung war der
verzicht auf gewalt zitat ende
gorbatschow versuchte letztlich nicht
das sowjet imperium mit militärischer
gewalt oder nuklearen drohungen zusammen
zu halten oder sich selbst mit gewalt
an die macht zu klammern
seine politik des erklärten gewalt zu
verzichten und seine aufgabe des
moskauer herrschaftsanspruchs gegen den
gegenüber den satelliten staaten stärken
die bürgerrechtsbewegung in mittel und
osteuropa seine entscheidung führten zur
freiheit für viele millionen menschen
michael gorbatschow selbst sagte dazu
1999 zehn jahre nach dem mauerfall hier
an diesem rednerpult und ich zitiere ihn
die tatsache dass die wiedervereinigung
gerade damals und gerade auf diese art
und weise stattgefunden hat ist ein
verdienst der völker
selbstzitat enden
die warschauer pakt staaten sollten
selbst über ihren weg entscheiden können
1989 und 1990 respektierte gorbatschow
ausdrücklich das selbstbestimmungsrecht
der völker
der kalte krieg ist zu ende verkündete
im dezember 1989 bei seinem treffen mit
us präsident george bush vor malta
bei seinem gipfeltreffen mit helmut kohl
in nordkaukasus im sommer 1990 stimmte
er auch der nato mitgliedschaft des
künftigen wiedervereinigten deutschlands
zu
am ende eines von zwei weltkriegen der
block konfrontation und der nuklearen
abschreckung geprägten jahrhunderts
erlebten wir einen friedlichen wandel
der auf mich oder
auch der für mich ehrlicherweise im
historischen rückblick ein ganz großes
glück war
insbesondere für unser land ein glück
für dass wir michael gorbatschow dankbar
bleiben werden
mit seiner versöhnungsbereitschaft
leistet der unschätzbares für die
historische aussöhnung zwischen
deutschen und russen die frage nach den
künftigen
deutsch-sowjetischen beziehungen
bewegten ihn wie auch 1990 immer wieder
an helmut kohl schrieb und auch wir in
deutschland haben uns eine
vertrauensvolle partnerschaft mit
russland gewünscht
ich sage mit großem bedauern dass eine
partnerschaft mit russland derzeit nicht
möglich ist
gorbatschow bezeichnete vertrauen als
den wichtigsten faktor in der
weltpolitik
mit vertrauen veränderte er die welt
sein vertrauen zu bundeskanzler kohl und
auch zu deutschland öffneten den weg zur
einheit unseres landes und für mich war
er einer der großen vertrauens stifter
des vergangenen jahrhunderts
dialog und vertrauen das war die
grundlage seines politischen handelns er
hatte den mut
eingefahrene wege zu verlassen die sich
als sackgasse erwiesen
er baute vertrauen auf zu es präsident
reagan und ersetzte vertrauen an die
stelle von abschreckung und
konfrontationen und das war eine
radikale kursänderung
dieses vertrauen wuchs auch als
gorbatschow von kompromissen sprachen
diese vokabel hatte man vorher selten
aus moskau gehört so brach er ausweglos
erscheinende konflikte auf
gorbatschow brachte neues denken in den
kreml er suchte die abkehr vom
gleichgewicht des nuklearen schreckens
mit dem bmf vertrag über die vernichtung
der atomaren mittelstreckenwaffen leute
zu gorbatschow und reagan
1987 das ende des nuklearen wettrüstens
zwischen den großmächten ein
mit der abrüstung wurde
weg zum friedlichen ende des kalten
krieges bereitet nach vier jahrzehnten
ost-west-konfrontation in europa
für seine abrüstungspolitik und für
seinen neuen weg in der außenpolitik
erhielt gorbatschow
1990 den friedensnobelpreis
als gorbatschow
1985 an der an die spitze der
sowjetunion aufstieg befand sich das
land bereits im niedergang
seine bürgerinnen und bürger lebten in
resignation
gorbatschow wollte mit reformen das
leben der sowjetbürger verbessern den
sozialismus weiterentwickeln ihm ein
menschliches antlitz geben er wollte die
angst in der beziehung zwischen dem volk
und der staatsführung ersetzen durch
dialog
auf einmal mischte sich dieser junge
staatsmann bei seiner ersten dienstreise
in das damalige leningrad und das volk
er fragte die menschen nach ihren sorgen
und problemen und er versprach änderung
seine offenheit und sein aktives werden
um die bevölkerung waren gar geradezu
unerhört hatte doch das volk in angst
vor der macht gelebt und die macht in
angst vor dem volk
glasnost und perestroika ging in die
internationale sprache ein
die neuen freiheiten wecken große
hoffnung nun konnte man in der
sowjetunion freisprechen ohne haftbefehl
befürchten zu müssen sogar über die
verbrechen des stalinismus und den gulag
wurde gesprochen archive wurden geöffnet
neue zeitungen bücher erinnerungen
erschienen
doch den niedergang des kolonialen
imperiums konnte gorbatschow nicht mehr
aufhalten
die sowjetunion war nicht mehr
reformiert sondern
gorbatschow der schritt für schritt
vorgehen wollte entglitt die kontrolle
über sein eigenes land im august 1991
wurde gegen ihn geputscht die völker der
sowjetunion
streben nach freiheit
und unabhängigkeit
am 25 dezember 1991 löste sich die
sowjetunion auf
es gibt wohl wenige politiker die in
deutschland so fair so viel verehrt
wurden wie er
und wir werden ihn als großen freiheit
geber in erinnerung behalten
die sehr unterschiedlichen reaktionen in
russland mittel und osteuropa und auch
in deutschland nach seinem tod zeigen
nicht nur die vielschichtigkeit seines
wirkens sie zeugen auch von
grundlegenden missverständnissen und der
tragik seines politischen lebens
er wurde einsam im eigenen land
in russland werden ihm der zerfall des
sowjetimperiums und die not der
neunzigerjahre angelastet er litt unter
dieser entfremdung von seinem eigenen
volk
im südkaukasus und im baltikum erinnert
man sich schmerzhaft an das brutale
vorgehen gegen friedliche
demonstrationen 1989 in tiflis den
schwarzen januar 1990 in aserbaidschan
und dem blutsonntag von vilnius 1991
während seiner amtszeit
es fand später trotz aller bewunderung
und dankbarkeit auch eine gewisse
entfremdung mit dem westen statt
etwa in der bewertung der russischen
außenpolitik von putin
gorbatschow war vom westen durchaus auch
enttäuscht er machte sich aber dabei
nicht leicht er zog sich nicht zurück
sondern engagierte sich weiter
gorbatschows verdienste um das ende des
kalten krieges und die wiedervereinigung
unseres landes und unseres kontinents
bleiben einzigartig
die unterschiedlichen reaktionen zeigen
aber wie rainer feser in der faz
vergangene woche anmerkte welche
missverständnisse und enttäuschungen
seit jahren zwischen russland und dem
westen bestehen
gerade wir deutschen haben zu lange
gorbatschows streben nach verständigung
frieden und partnerschaft als grundlage
unserer beziehungen mit russland
vorausgesetzt dabei haben wir übersehen
oder vielleicht auch nicht wahrhaben
wollen dass sich russland unter putin
längst und radikal von gorbatschows
zielen abgewandt hatte
die entwicklung in seiner heimat
besorgte gorbatschow er rief die
regierenden in russland auf keine angst
vor den menschen zu haben und auch ihre
freiheit nicht zu unterdrücken
gleichzeitig setzt er vertrauen in die
russische zivilgesellschaft
besonders in die jungen menschen
russlands zukunft kann nur demokratie
bedeuten schrieb er 2009 10
gorbatschow war trotz aller rückschläge
und defizite zutiefst davon überzeugt
dass es letztlich kein zurück zur
totalitären vergangenheit geben er war
sich sicher dass nur eine demokratische
entwicklung seinem land eine zukunft
bieten kann
vor wenigen jahren sagte michael
gorbatschow in einem interview um
interview wir wollten die mauern des
misstrauens zwischen ost und west
beseitigen überhaupt jede mauer zwischen
staaten zwischen völkern zwischen
menschen zitat ende
zwischen russland und europa kraft heute
ein tiefer graben dort
wo nach gorbatschows vision ein
gemeinsames europäisches haus entstehen
sollte
mit russland und mit einer gemeinsamen
sicherheitsarchitektur
im juni 1990 schrieb er an helmut kohl
dass die überwindung des blogs systems
und die gestaltung neuer
sicherheitsstrukturen im
gesamteuropäischen geiste zu suchen sein
es ist russland das unter putin mit
diesem geist gebrochen hat und das ist
ein tragischer fehler
es ist russland das die ukraine angreift
und mit waffengewalt die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört
gorbatschow war ein mann des friedens
als kind hatte er den zweiten weltkrieg
erlebt und er wollte die welt von ihrer
größten bedrohung befreien immer wieder
mahnte er zur atomaren abrüstung und
warnte eindringlich vor der gefahr eines
neuen krieges
eine neuerliche konfrontation russlands
mit den westen blieb bis zuletzt seine
größte sorge
michael gorbatschow stand für
gewaltverzicht für freiheit und für die
selbstbestimmung der völker er stand für
eine weltordnung in der staaten durch
dialog und auf grundlage des rechts
konflikte beilegen und gemeinsamen
lösungen für globale probleme suchen
es schmerzt uns zutiefst dass alles
wofür er stand heute auf so eklatanter
weise verletzt und zerstört wird
gorbatschows mut kann uns aber auch in
diesen dunklen stunden
zuversicht vermitteln für die großen
herausforderungen vor denen wir jetzt
stehen er war humanist
er glaubte an die menschen und ihre
möglichkeiten
man kann wenn man will betonte er immer
wieder
selbst unter schwierigen bedingungen
lassen sich so meinte er neue lösungen
im interesse der welten gemeinschaft
finden man darf nicht aufgeben und sein
handeln war das beste beispiel dafür
[Applaus]
die welt muss nicht bleiben wie sie ist
auch nicht nach diesem brutalen krieg
den russland gegen die ukraine führt es
kann ein besseres morgen ein besseres
übermorgen geben aber der weg dahin wird
sicherlich lang und auch steinig wir
brauchen mutige menschen die für eine
friedliche gerechte und nachhaltige welt
bereit sind risiken einzugehen und
eingetretene pfade zu verlassen
die bereit sind neu zu denken und zu
handeln
politiker und persönlichkeiten wie
michael
gorbatschow
mit ihm verliert das deutsche volk einen
treuen freund
ich verneige mich vor dem großen welt
verändere und dem großartigen menschen
ich möchte sie jetzt bitten sich als
zeichen des respekts unserer dankbarkeit
und unserer trauer in gedenken an
michael gorbatschow von den plätzen zu
erheben für eine schweigeminute
ich danke ihm bitte nehmen sie wieder
platz
wir unterbrechen die sitzung jetzt und
werden um 39 mit der sitzung
fortfahren herzlichen dank
so das war die bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas die vor allem die bedeutung
gorbatschows für frieden und freiheit
für deutschland hervor hob zur
erinnerung an michael gorbatschow zeigen
wir nun einen kleinen rückblick ein
bericht von anne gellinek
der im westen gefeierte reformer war in
seinem lebensende in russland ein
einsamer mann er musste mit ansehen wie
sein nach nachfolger wladimir putin sein
lebenswerk schritt für schritt
demontierten
die perestroika ist abgebrochen worden
jetzt geht es wieder rückwärts aber
wladimir putin wird damit keinen erfolg
haben es wird ihm nicht gelingen nur mit
angst und schrecken zu regieren hoffte
gorbatschow bis zum schluss
1931 wird er in diesem haus ins tableau
pohl in südrussland geboren seine eltern
sind bauern der gelehrige sohn machte
eine steile karriere in der
kommunistischen partei steigt zum gebiet
sekretär auf und geht schließlich nach
moskau zuständig für landwirtschaft
1985 wird er als jüngstes
politbüromitglied zum generalsekretär
der kommunistischen partei bestimmt und
mit ihm weht ein frischer wind durch die
verkrustete sowjetunion in
atemberaubendem tempo beendet er den
kalten krieg er trifft sich mit dem
amerikanischen präsidenten ronald reagan
schlägt vor die atomwaffen zu halbieren
und stimmt der deutschen
wiedervereinigung zu
[Applaus]
1990 treffen sich bundeskanzler kohl und
staatschefs gorbatschow zum strickjacken
gipfel im kaukasus um die details der
deutschen einigung auszuhandeln
im westen ist gorbi ein gefeierter held
zusammen mit seiner frau raissa
bezaubert er die ganze welt
innenpolitisch aber bleibt gorbatschow
glücklos er versteht nichts von ökonomie
der niedergang ist nicht aufzuhalten die
wirtschaft bricht zusammen die
sowjetunion zerfällt die russen
assoziieren fortan demokratie mit chaos
gorbatschow verliert die macht an den
neuen starken mann boris jelzin in
russland ist der reformer zu einer
tragischen figur geworden
seinen 80 geburtstag feierte michael
gorbatschow in london in der royal
albert hall auf gratulanten aus dem
kreml wartete der mann der die welt
veränderte vergebens
soviel zu michael gorbatschow gleich
geht es hier weiter mit der
generaldebatte
zuvor jedoch muss der bundestag umgebaut
werden circa 39 soll es weitergehen ich
nutze die zeit um grüße hier bei mir im
studium meine kolleginnen aus dem
hauptstadtstudio ines trams hallo was
ist denn heute erwarten traditionell
eröffnet ja die opposition spricht heute
friedrich merz die generaldebatte es gab
ja schon im vorfeld heftige kritik von
ihm am entlastungs paket an
wirtschaftsminister haarweg was ist er
heute zu erwarten ganz genau
generaldebatte ist die sternstunde des
parlaments und die sternstunde der
opposition friedrich merz wird die
debatte eröffnen und er hat den ton
dafür bereits in interviews in den tagen
zuvor gesetzt ich denke er wird die
regierung namentlich minister hahn beck
scharf für handwerkliche fehler
kritisieren stichwort gas umlage und er
wird ebenso scharf denke ich die
regierung insgesamt dafür kritisieren
dass sie nicht die drei noch aktiven
atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen lassen wird
zuvor hat er schon gewarnt wenn in
deutschland die lichter ausgingen dann
seien nicht mehr putin schuld sondern
tatsächlich scholz und seine regierung
vielen dank erstmal hierhin wir reden
nachher noch weiter und schalten jetzt
mal in den bundestag zu meiner kollegin
andrea maurer die vor ort ist und dort
ein gesprächspartner von der opposition
hat
ja guten morgen patricia bei mir ist
jetzt der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der unions-fraktion
thorsten frei guten morgen herr frey
have frei der oppositionsführer
friedrich merz wird diese debatte
eröffnen ihre partei und fraktionschef
es heißt er will heute den kanzler und
den vizekanzler nicht schon das ganze
klingt nach generalabrechnung was ist
aus der konstruktiven opposition
geworden die sie mal in dieser krise
sein wollten nein es ist keine general
abrechnung aber es ist eine
generaldebatte und wir sind an einem
punkt der deutschen politik angelangt wo
man glaube ich schon sehr klar deutlich
machen muss wie dieses land aus der
krise geführt werden kann die
bundesregierung tut es nicht die
streitet sich vor allen dingen wie die
kesselflicker egal um welches thema es
geht ob es um die frage der
laufzeitverlängerung von kernkraftwerken
geht ob es um die entlastung für die
bürgerinnen und bürger geht wie man
damit umgeht dass durch die stark
gestiegenen energiepreise ja auch der
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland unter
druck gerät und bei all diesen zentralen
fragen bekommen wir keine antworten
heute ist generaldebatte heute ist die
zeit sich zu erklären und transparent zu
machen wie es durch die krise gehen
sollen herr frey stichwort
laufzeitverlängerung die union macht
sich jetzt daran die verantwortung für
eine mögliche energiekrise im winter der
regierung zu geben aber wie steht es
denn um ihre verantwortung die union war
ja lange in regierungsverantwortung und
ist sozusagen an dieser energie krise
nicht ganz mit unschuldig also zunächst
einmal ist es so dass wir gemeinsam
entschieden haben aus der kohleenergie
auszusteigen aus der atomenergie
auszusteigen ohne die frage schlüssig zu
beantworten wie denn diese lücke dann
gefüllt werden soll alle aber
insbesondere die grünen haben dabei voll
auf gas gesetzt und das ist etwas was
tatsächlich jetzt zum problem wird die
verantwortung der bundesregierung ist es
aber in dieser situation an einer
verringerung des problems zu arbeiten
sie tut aber das gegenteil dadurch dass
in den vorschlägen der bundesregierung
die kapazitätsausweitung gar keine rolle
spielt egal ob bei biomasse oder
kernenergie führt dass am ende zur
verteuerung und auch zur verknappung von
energie und damit ist diese
bundesregierung der
bundeswirtschaftsminister aber weiter
nichts tut auch der bundeskanzler
persönlich dafür verantwortlich wenn wir
in eine knappheit situation im winter
gehen noch mal kurz zur verantwortung
vom kanzler also herr merz hat ja gesagt
man muss inzwischen darauf gefasst sein
dass dieser kanzler vorzeitig scheitern
könnte das hat er am wochenende gesagt
wie konkret spielen sie als union ein
solches scheitern denn eigentlich durch
das brauchen wir nicht wir sind eine
kraft eine bürgerliche oppositionspartei
wir adressieren die probleme die da
bestehen wir machen bessere vorschläge
und wir sind jederzeit bereit
verantwortung für unser land zu
übernehmen danke schön herr frey sie
gehen jetzt rein in die generaldebatte
an dieser stelle und damit erstmal
zurück ins studium
ja herzlichen dank andrea gleich wird es
noch einen weiteren gesprächspartner
dort geben solange aber die frage jetzt
erneut an ines trams wir haben dass er
eben schon gehört von thorsten frei also
es wird heftige angriffe geben auf die
regierung auf wirtschaftsminister habe
aber wie sehr unter druck steht im
augenblick der bundeskanzler und auch
der wirtschaftsminister ich denke
bundeskanzler scholz steht unter druck
muss heute das dritte entlastungspaket
verteidigen wuchtig und zielgenau so
charakterisiert er ist ja selber doch
genau das muss sich noch zeigen ist es
tatsächlich wusste ich die finanzierung
die ist ja noch nicht so ganz gesichert
in einigen teilen und auch die
zielgenauigkeit wird von einigen
kritikern bezweifelt derweil haben die
menschen draußen druck haben sorgen vor
den explodierenden preisen
koalitionsintern soll finanzminister
lindner ja von einer lawine gesprochen
haben die da auf das land zurollt und
kanzler scholz muss nun heute das machen
was er eigentlich nicht so gut kann er
muss erklären er muss den menschen
erklären wie will er sie schützen
sichern vor dieser lawine ja ich bin
gespannt ob er das hinkriegt ich höre
jetzt das im bundestag meine kollegin
andrea maurer den nächsten
gesprächspartner hat diesmal von der fdp
ja bei mir ist der generalsekretär der
fdp bijan djir sarai guten morgen herr
gießerei
herr gießerei es heißt der fdp chef
lindner hätte intern vor einer lawine
gewarnt die auf dieses land zu rollt
eine lawine ist schwer aufzuhalten auch
politisch nicht vor mit welchen
szenarien rechnen sie also zunächst
einmal dass die zeiten ernst sind das
ist bekannt dass wir uns derzeit in
deutschland alle große sorgen machen
beispielsweise über die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung in diesem land die frage
energiepreise wie geht es weiter in
diesem land im winter im herbst im
nächsten jahr das in der zeit themen die
uns intensiv beschäftigen aber sie sehen
dass die koalition nicht nur
diskussionsfähig ist sondern auch
handlungsfähig sie ist auch streikfähig
hat man den eindruck er stichwort
laufzeitverlängerung da sind sie ja im
offenen dissens mit dem
wirtschaftsminister harbeck der kanzler
hat sich gestern hinter robert habeck
gestellt und gesagt diese regierung wird
nun einvernehmlich handeln heißt dass
die fdp wird einem akw notbetrieb einen
notbetrieb von zwei lkws bis früher
zustimmen es geht hier nicht um die fdp
es geht hier auch nicht um parteien oder
parteipolitik sondern es geht um die
frage wie wir die nächsten monate die
nächsten jahre in diesem land gestalten
werden und vor allem wie wir es schaffen
eine energiekrise in deutschland zu
verhindern das ist eine sachliche
nüchterne debatte ich würde begrüßen
wenn parteipolitik hier keine rolle
spielen würde sie haben völlig recht wir
sehen das an der stelle anders aber sie
haben dass er auch bei anderen
beispielen gesehen in der
koalition wird intensiv diskutiert aber
diese koalition ist am ende des tages
immer handlungsfähig ist immer in der
lage gewesen auch gute lösungen für das
land zu präsentieren und ich bin davon
überzeugt dass wir es auch in diesem
fall schaffen werden jetzt sei die
generaldebatte beginnt jetzt gleich
vielen dank an dieser stelle schon mal
und damit auch zurück ins studio zu dir
patricia
ja herzlichen dank ich habe das plenum
im blick als ich sehe noch hat es nicht
begonnen deswegen spreche ich noch
weiter mit ihnen ist aber sobald sich
was tut sobald friedrich merz zum
rednerpult geht schalten wir natürlich
sofort ein wir haben es eben gehört es
wurde schon mal angesprochen
die finanzierung dieses gewaltigen
entlastungspaket also das neue war jetzt
65 milliarden wenn man alle drei
zusammen nimmt sind es 95 milliarden der
finanzminister tut so kann man fast
sagen als sei die finanzierung kein
problem ich denke mal die opposition
sieht das anders da sind doch noch ganz
viele offene fragen oder absolut richtig
da sind einige stellschrauben noch nicht
ganz fest gezurrt möchte ich mal sagen
finanzminister lindner rechnet zum einen
mit höheren einnahmen des staates
aufgrund der inflation aufgrund der
höheren preise arbeit das ist bislang
tatsächlich auch nur eine prognose zum
anderen möchte er den strommarkt neu
sortieren und sogenannte zufalls gewinne
abschöpfen da will man jetzt in die
diskussion mit der eu gehen aber diese
diskussion beginnt eben auch erst gerade
und mit blick auf das 9 euro ticket ja
das soll fortgeführt werden als 49 euro
für 69 euro ticket da möchte man aber
bei der finanzierung die länder mit
einbeziehen einige länder beschweren
sich bereits jetzt schon dass sie
bislang noch gar nicht mit einbezogen
noch gar nicht gefragt worden seien also
einige stellschrauben bei der
finanzierung tatsächlich noch nicht
festgezurrt wie könnte man denn im
augenblick die atmosphäre in der
koalition beschreiben nach meseberg
hatte man ja den eindruck man hat sich
wieder zusammengerauft das ist wieder
friedlich jetzt gibt es wieder heftige
attacken von seiten der fdp zum beispiel
auf die grünen wie ist in so einem
augenblick die atmosphäre ganz genau bei
meseberg hatte man den eindruck alle
drei koalitionäre haben realisiert so in
dem ton wie es zuvor der fall war kann
es nicht weiter gehen angesichts der
krisen muss man sich zusammenraufen nun
haben wir seit beginn der woche den
streit um die laufzeiten der
atomkraftwerke ich denke es läuft
irgendwann auf kanzler stolz zu wird er
da weiter als vorsichtiger
zurückhaltender moderator unterwegs sein
oder wird er irgendwann ein machtwort
sprechen also der stresstest der jetzt
zu dieser akw entscheidung von
wirtschaftsminister harbeck geführt hat
kann tatsächlich auch zwick rest für die
koalition werden ganz herzlichen dank
ich höre oder sehe jetzt gerade
friedrich merz ist auf dem weg zum
rednerpult und jetzt hören wir ein
eröffnet traditionell generaldebatte
kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist mehr als angemessen dass wir
heute morgen dem verstorbenen letzten
staatspräsidenten der ehemaligen
sowjetunion und generalsekretär der kp
de su gedacht haben
wir verdanken helmut kohl george bush
und eben auch michael gorbatschow dies
soll
über 30 jahren die wiedervereinigung in
frieden und freiheit erreichen
hätte gorbatschow seinen politischen weg
weitergehen können wären
glasnost und perestroika die prägenden
elemente der russischen politik
nach dem ende der sowjetunion geblieben
dann wären nicht nur die russische
geschichte anders verlaufen
die gesamte europäische geschichte wäre
anders verlaufen
aber spätestens seit dem russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine sind wir
auf schreckliche weise mit einer ganz
anderen realität konfrontiert und diese
realität hat folgen für ganz europa aber
auch und ganz besonders für deutschland
wir haben seit ihrer regierungserklärung
herr bundeskanzler am 27 februar über
diese folgen oft und intensiv diskutiert
wir haben gemeinsame entscheidungen
getroffen bis hin zu einer änderung des
grundgesetzes
und einer gemeinsamen entschließung des
deutschen bundestages am 28 april über
umfassende humanitäre finanzielle und
militärische hilfe für die ukraine
mit diesen beiden entscheidungen enden
dann aber auch die gemeinsamkeiten
zwischen ihrer regierung und obst soweit
der bundeshaushalt betroffen ist über
den wir in dieser woche in erster lesung
beraten
halten sie ihre eigene zusagen nicht ein
herr bundeskanzler der bundeswehr zitat
sie erinnern sich möglicherweise ab
sofort jedes jahr ab sofort jedes jahr
mehr als zwei prozent des bip für
investitionen in die bündnisse und
verteidigungsfähigkeit zur verfügung zu
stellen der bundeswehr hätte neben den
100 milliarden euro die wir zusammen
geschlossen haben jahr für jahr
ansteigen müssen stattdessen kürzen sie
von diesem jahr auf das nächste jahr den
etat um 300 millionen euro
herr bundeskanzler wir müssen es leider
feststellen wir können den von ihnen
gegebenen zusagen nicht vertrauen
neben den rein finanziellen fragen der
ausstattung der bundeswehr kommen sie
und ihre regierung auch der eindeutigen
aufforderung des deutschen bundestages
vom 28 april nicht nach die ukraine in
ausreichendem maße mit schweren waffen
zu versorgen und fällt niemandem von uns
leicht zu verstehen dass der einsatz von
waffen den frieden näher bringen kann
aber lassen sie mich vielleicht zitieren
aus einem interview lassen sie mich
zitieren aus einem interview dass einer
der renommiertesten national und
international anerkannten
politikwissenschaftler unseres landes
vor zwei wochen in der berliner zeitung
gegeben hat das ist herfried münkler er
sagt ich bin erstaunt über die naivität
eines teils der intellektuellen szene
und mancher politiker in deutschland die
offenbar glauben dass putin an den
verhandlungstisch kommen wird wenn man
ihn dazu auffordert das gegenteil ist
der fall
russland so sagt er muss durch
militärische misserfolge zu gesprächen
mit der ukraine gezwungen werden werden
mit waffenlieferungen aus dem ausland
beschleunigt man also einen prozess an
dessen ende verhandlungen stehen
in deutschland
gibt es offenbar keine kultur des
militärisch strategischen denkens
deswegen werden diese aus expertensicht
absurden forderungen nicht als falsch
erkannt der weg so schließt er an den
verhandlungstisch wird einzig über
militärische erfolge der ukraine die
russland die aussicht auf den großen
sieg nehmen ende des zitats der
bundeskanzler
der bundeskanzler
diese klaren worte
diese klaren worte hätten wir einmal von
ihnen erwartet damit hätten sie nicht
nur in deutschland sondern damit hätten
sie für ganz europa ein bisschen
politische führung übernommen
die worte von herfried münkler ernst und
wir tun das dann ist die zögerlichkeit
der
ukraine noch intensiver zu helfen einen
grund dafür dass dieser krieg sich
verlängert er fordert noch mehr opfer
auf beiden seiten als dieser krieg
ohnehin schon gefordert hat die länge
dieses krieges verschärft auch die
wirtschaftliche lage in deutschland und
in europa wir müssen heute meine damen
und herren davon ausgehen dass vor allem
deutschland aufgrund seiner ich sage
ausdrücklich nicht von dieser regierung
allein zu verantwortenden
energieabhängigkeit von russland in
besonderem maße von diesem drohenden
versorgungsengpässen
ich habe es doch gerade gesagt
ausdrücklich nicht von ihnen allein zu
verantworten der abhängigkeit von
russischem gas in besonderer weise
betroffen
jenseits aller details
meine damen und herren jenseits aller
details und ich werde auf zwei zu
sprechen kommen fehlt ihnen und ihrer
regierung aber auch in
wirtschaftspolitischer hinsicht jeder
kompass ja man muss es leider sagen auch
in der wirtschaftspolitik fehlt dieser
bundesregierung jede fähigkeit zum
politisch strategischen denken
die mühen und streiten sich über wochen
und monate die gesamte sommerpause ist
doch bestimmt gewesen von einem
permanenten streik dieser koalition über
wochen und herausgekommen ist wieder
einmal ein sammelsurium an kompromissen
auf dem niveau des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners den diese koalition noch
zusammenhält weit davon entfernt weit
davon entfernt
sachgerechte antworten auf diese
gewaltigen herausforderungen zu gehen
vor denen wir stehen und lassen sie mich
meine damen und herren beginnt mit einer
rein formalen frage der frage der
zuständigkeiten spätestens diese krise
und das durcheinander in ihrer koalition
hätten sie herr bundeskanzler zum anlass
nehmen müssen im bundeskanzleramt einen
energie sicherheitsrat noch besser einen
nationalen sicherheitsrat aus
mitgliedern der bundesregierung und
experten von außen einzurichten
spätestens diese krise wäre veranlassen
gewesen die zuständigkeit an sich zu
ziehen wenn sie können die hoch
komplexen fragen der energiepolitik und
der versorgungssicherheit unseres landes
in einer solchen existenziellen krise
doch nicht allen ernstes einen
bundeswirtschaftsminister überlassen der
zwar wie wir immer wieder sehen gefällig
formulieren kann dem wir immer wieder
beim denken zuschauen dürfen der aber
umgeben ist sie aber umgeben ist ganz
offensichtlich in seiner partei und in
seinem apparat von einer gruppe aus
lobbyisten der umweltpolitik die alles
zur strecke bringen was auch nur
einigermaßen aussicht auf erfolg hat
diese diese in dem netzwerk
und mit verlaub wie hilflos er habe sie
in diesen fragen sind das konnte man
gestern abend im deutschen fernsehen
beobachten man kann nur hoffen man kann
nur hoffen dass
ein großteil der deutschen
mittelständischen unternehmer und vor
allem der bäckerinnen und bäcker um
diese uhrzeit schon im bett gelegen
haben und geschlafen haben um das nicht
mit ansehen mussten was sie da gestern
abend folgen die man kann nur hoffen
das problem
das große problem vor dem wir heute
stehen meine damen und herren ist die
hohe geldentwertung die jahrelange nur
zinspolitik der ezb hat den sparern in
deutschland erst die renditen
vorenthalten und jetzt geht es an die
substanz und noch weitreichender sind
die folgen noch weitreichender sind die
folgen für unsere gesamte
volkswirtschaft viele unternehmen ja wie
sie diese zwischenrufe meine damen und
herren zeigen nur dass sie ganz
offensichtlich keine ahnung von dem
haben was in den privaten haushalten und
in den unternehmen im augenblick in
deutschland los wir haben offensichtlich
keine ahnung ich gebe ihnen mal ein
beispiel
viele unternehmen viele unternehmen in
deutschland haben die auftragsbücher im
augenblick so voll wie schon seit jahren
nicht mehr aber sie können diese
aufträge nicht abarbeiten sie geben sie
zurück weil die lieferketten
unterbrochen sind weil die preise durch
die decke gehen und weil sie nicht mehr
in der lage sind die aufträge
abzuarbeiten diesen schon seit längerer
zeit in den büchern stehen haben das hat
etwas mit der inflationsrate und der
geldentwertung und den lieferketten zu
tun schauen sie sich das doch bitte in
ihren wahlkreisen einmal an jeder von
uns bekommt jeden tag nachrichten und
briefe aus den unternehmen die genau auf
diesen sachverhalt hinweisen und sie
gehen mit einer bemerkenswerten ignoranz
über dieses thema hinweg und reden nur
über hilfsprogramme stadt einmal das
thema wirklich an der wurzel zu packen
sucht man in ihrem papier vom
vergangenen sonntag nach lösungen zu
diesem problem stößt man vor allem
gratulation an die fdp dass sie die
kalte progression abbauen wollen meine
damen und herren das steht im gesetz
dass sie das ohnehin machen müssen und
sie sind dazu verpflichtet diese frage
alle zwei jahre zu klären und es gibt
doch zumindest eine moralische
verpflichtung das jetzt zu tun und nicht
erst im jahr 2023 sondern jetzt im jahr
2022 wäre die richtige antwort im jahr
der krise gewesen diese entscheidung zu
treffen
stattdessen stattdessen halten sie fest
stattdessen halten sie fest an der
gasanlage die zum ersten oktober nun in
kraft treten sollen diese gas umlage
wird die inflationsrate in deutschland
noch weiter in die höhe treiben sie wird
die privaten haushalte noch höher
belasten und sie wird vor allen dingen
die unternehmen in deutschland zu einem
zeitpunkt wo sie es nun überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen können mit tausenden
hunderttausenden millionen zusätzlicher
kosten belasten nur weil sie in dieser
bundesregierung krampfhaft an dieser
umlage festhalten die von anfang an eine
fehlkonstruktion gewesen ist und sie
nicht die kraft haben das jetzt hier zu
korrigieren es wäre richtig gewesen
es wäre richtig gewesen
diese umlage aufzunehmen sie können das
übrigens mit uns zusammen in dieser
woche tun der entsprechende antrag der
liegt im deutschen bundestag vor und
statt dessen die relevanten unternehmen
die gasimporte importeure unter einen
staatlichen schutzschirm zu stellen so
wie wir das mit den banken in der
finanzkrise und mit einigen unternehmen
wegen da während der korona krise einmal
gemacht haben dies ist die systematik
die instrumente sind vorhanden sie
weigern sich auf diese instrumente
zurückgreifen weil sie mit dem kopf
durch die wand wollen und eine einmal
geschlossene entscheidung nicht
zurücknehmen wollen das ist die wahrheit
mit dieser gattung markt
kommt
nun kommt das meisterstück dieser
regierung nämlich die entscheidung vom
montag dieser woche über den
atomausstieg ich meine damen und herren
zunächst einmal vor der klammert damit
das klar ist natürlich muss man den
menschen in einer solchen situation
helfen wenn die energiepreise steigen
wenn die privaten haushalte hoch
belastet sind muss man helfen und sie
haben durchaus in dem papier vom
vergangenen sonntag einige wichtige
beschlüsse gefasst ich nenne ihnen mal
nur zwei an der zahl
sie beschweren sich doch darüber dass
wir zu viel kritisieren jetzt sage ich
mal etwas sage ich ihnen mal etwas wo
sie richtig liegen sie haben gottseidank
gesehen dass sie die rentnerinnen und
rentner und die studierenden in
deutschland übersehen haben bei dem
letzten hilfspaket und korrigieren das
jetzt aber er bundeskanzler jetzt mal
ganz im ernst 300 euro für jeden
haushalt sie und ich bekomme das in
diesen tagen auch überwiesen
brauchen sie das brauchen wir das oder
gibt es vielleicht in diesem land
haushalte mit einem
durchschnittseinkommen von vielleicht
1500 1600 euro im monat netto die er
1000 euro gebraucht hätten statt alle
300 es wäre besser gewesen dass auf
diejenigen konzentrieren die hilfe
brauchen das mit der gießkanne russland
zu gehen und jedem haushalt einen
solchen betrag zu überweisen ich will
eine zweite ich will eine zweite
entscheidung nennen die in der
presseberichterstattung wie ich finde
bedauerlicherweise etwas zu sehr in den
hintergrund getreten ist die
entscheidung die tarifvertragsparteien
das angebot zu machen einen einmalbetrag
von 3000 euro zu verabreden der dann
steuer und abgabenfrei ist ist richtig
und ich will von dieser stelle auch den
tarifvertragsparteien sagen nehmen sie
dieses angebot in anspruch damit sie
jetzt möglichst schnell den privaten
haushalt mit einer solchen einmalzahlung
helfen das ist eine richtige
entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
aber meine damen und herren das sind
doch das sind doch alles reparaturen an
einem problem das sie in der wurzel
nicht anfassen wir haben es mit dieser
gaspreisentwicklung mit einem
klassischen
angebotsschock zu tun was macht man wenn
man einen solchen angebots
schockerlebnis dann versucht man doch
zunächst einmal
darauf zu reagieren indem man alle
möglichkeiten nutzt das vorhandene
angebot das immer noch zur verfügung
steht auszuschöpfen und zwar mit ganzer
kraft und jede möglichkeit zu nutzen
das lernt man meine damen und herren das
nennt man marktwirtschaft der ein oder
andere wird diesen begriff von ihm schon
mal gehört haben so reagiert man in
einer marktwirtschaft auf einen
angebotsschock und diese reaktion wäre
richtig gewesen im hinblick auf die
gesamte palette der energieversorgung
die wir in diesem lande haben
stattdessen wird in dieser regierung
weiter verzögert herum laviert
verhindert und wertvolle zeit vergeudet
ich nenne ihnen ein beispiel beispiele
da sind die steinkohlekraftwerke dem sie
erst die betriebserlaubnis geben wieder
hochzufahren wenn für mehrere wochen die
reserven auf dem hof liegen das gilt für
die biomasse wir haben hier darüber
gesprochen sie wollten den deckel
aufheben des bis heute bei 1000 mw
gedeckelt es nach wie vor vorhanden aus
biomasse könnte das zehnfache an strom
gewonnen werden was wir heute unter
diesem deckel
haben das gilt für die
das geht für die braunkohlekraftwerke
von denen immer noch einige blöcke
stillstehen und das ergebnis ist dass
wir im jahr 2022 mehr gas verströmt
haben als in vielen jahren vorher wir
sind in einem land in die in einer zeit
in der gas gespart werden muss
gespeichert werden muss und durch ihre
blockadehaltung gegenüber anderen formen
der stromerzeugung fahren die in
deutschland die gaskraftwerke hoch und
erzeugen strom obwohl es andere
möglichkeiten gäbe diesen strom zu
erzeugen und dann und dann diese
entscheidung
dann diese entscheidung meine damen und
herren zur kernenergie
was sie da am montag verkündet haben er
habe jetzt hat das parlament schon
verlassen
wahrscheinlich guckt dass ich gerade mal
die filme von gestern abend dann
aber meine damen und herren was da am
montagabend was da am montagabend
verkündet worden ist das beruhigt
möglicherweise die grüne basis vor allem
in niedersachsen in wahrheit halten sie
mit dieser politik das ganze land zum
lachen und beschädigen möglicherweise
unwiderruflich die deutschen unternehmen
den gesamten wirtschaftsstandort und vor
allem die mittelständischen unternehmen
in unserem land
damit
und lag damit dass
von dieser stelle aus klar wird weil die
das hin und wieder auch anders in
deutschland verbreiten niemand von uns
will zurück zur alten kernenergie
[Applaus]
also vielleicht muss ich so für sie
vielleicht muss ich für sie noch mal
wiederholen damit sie es verstehen
niemand von uns will zurück zur alten
kernenergie die wir 2011 in deutschland
beendet haben aber in einer
die ganze die ganze ignoranz zu diesem
thema die steht ihnen ins gesicht
geschrieben wenn man von dieser stelle
aus wenn man von dieser aktie auf strich
sagen wir haben wir haben in deutschland
wir haben in deutschland noch drei
laufende kernkraftwerke das sind die
modernsten und sichersten
kernkraftwerke der welt die ganze welt
drum herum schaut auf deutschland und
draußen sagen die leute sind diese
deutschen eigentlich verrückt geworden
in einer solchen situation drei
kernkraftwerke stillzulegen kinder lage
wären millionen haushalte sicher mit
strom zu versorgen
meine damen und herren das ist doch das
ist das hat doch ein niveau an die
nationalität erreicht das kann man doch
gar nicht mehr beschreiben wir haben
ihnen das angebot gemacht in den
sommerferien eine sondersitzung des
deutschen bundestages durchzuführen mit
einer änderung des atomgesetzes
wir hätten mit ihnen gemeinsam den weg
gegangen dies für drei oder vier jahre
zu ermöglichen nicht mehr aber bitte
auch nicht weniger aber das was sie
jetzt da machen ist doch ein fauler
kompromiss die beiden atomkraftwerke die
nach ihrem willen im standby betrieb
bleiben sollen und alle fachleute sagen
ihnen dass das hochgradiger unfug ist
das zu machen müssen die komplette
mannschaft vorhalten bleiben am netz
sollen hochgefahren werden wenn wir ein
problem in deutschland habe ich sage
ihnen wir werden nicht nur ein problem
aber sie haben vor einigen wochen mal
gesagt wir hätten keinen strom problem
wir hätten ein gas problem wir sind
mittendrin in einem massiven
stromproblem in diesem land und sie
haben es offensichtlich bis heute nicht
verstanden dass es so ist so und wenn
sie wenn sie dafür sorgen dass die
preise runtergehen in deutschland dass
die hilfsmaßnahmen die wir gemeinsam
vielleicht ergreifen müssen nicht
überborden und den haushalt
überstrapazieren dann muss man auf der
angebotsseite alles tun damit genug
strom damit genug energie in diesem
lande verfügbar ist und das ist keine
frage der netzstabilität die hat sie
haben prüfen lassen das ist eine frage
der stromerzeugung kapazitäten in
deutschland prägen sie sich mal nicht
auf die parlaments- ärztin ist da wenn
sie wollen können sie gleich hier
also ein reines für ihn sagen bei 1 zu
ihnen sagen wenn sie wenn sie mit ihrer
fraktion der meinung sind diese probleme
die wir jetzt haben zum gegenstand von
auseinandersetzungen auf den straßen in
deutschland machen zu wollen dann werden
wir ihnen mit allem was wir haben und
notfalls mit allen anderen zusammen im
parlament entgegen treten wir werden es
nicht zulassen dass sie dieses lampen
ihrer politik stabilisieren das wäre
und was machen wir dann nochmals mit
allen anderen tiefen und sie verhindern
dass sie da ihr braunes kunstepochen
nein meine damen und herren herr
bundeskanzler
ich will es ihnen aus wirklich sagen für
auf zeit muss diese kapazitäten am netz
bleiben damit sinken wir die preise
damit senken wir die kosten für die
unternehmen damit schaffen wir
planungssicherheit auch für die
unternehmen in deutschland und ich will
sie aufrufen die lage spitzt sich in den
nächsten tagen wochen und monaten
möglicherweise dramatisch zu und sie
wissen dass sie haben die
gesprächspartner die ihnen das gesagt
haben das dürfte alles andere als eine
übertreibung sein ich sage ihnen herr
bundeskanzler stoppen sie diesen irrsinn
aus ihrer koalition so lange wir die
zeit dafür noch herzlichen dank
das war cdu chef friedrich merz mit
heftigen attacken auf die regierung er
warf ihr vor zu zögerlich bei
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine zu sein
es fehlen jeder kompass beim thema
wirtschaft die regierung sei nur noch zu
einer einigung auf den kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner in der lage besonders
heftig attackierte friedrich merz
wirtschaftsminister habeck der rein
ideologische politik mache vor allem
beim thema atomenergie mal sehen ob der
nächste redner bundeskanzler olaf scholz
seinem wirtschaftsminister gleich den
rücken stärkt
nächster redner für die bundesregierung
bundeskanzler olaf scholz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
verehrten kolleginnen kollegen
fährt der kollege merz ich habe ihnen
eben sehr genau zugehört
ich will ich will ihnen einst antworten
und das schätzen sie unser land nicht
unterschätzen sie nicht die bürgerinnen
und bürger dieses landes
in schweren zeiten wächst unser land
über sich selbst hinaus wir haben eine
gute tradition uns unter zu haken wenn
es schwierig wird bund länder und
kommunen politik zivilgesellschaft
arbeitgeber und betriebsräte unternehmen
und gewerkschaften der spaltung
herbeiredet der gefährde den
zusammenhalt in diesem land und das ist
jetzt das falsche
und außerdem ist es so dass wir in einer
situation sind in der die union die
meisten probleme schon als gelöst
vorgefunden hat bevor sie sie überhaupt
erörtert hat ich will das mal ganz klar
sagen bereits im dezember habe ich die
zuständigen minister gefragt was ist
eigentlich wenn wir schwierigkeiten
kriegen mit lieferungen aus russland und
wir haben uns bis zum kriegsausbruch
darauf sorgfältig vorbereitet um dann in
dieser situation entscheidung zu treffen
die weitreichend sind und die
weitreichend auch jetzt schon umgesetzt
worden sind etwas auch dass niemand
anders sich vorbereitet hat
wir haben zum beispiel entschieden um
mit dieser bedrohung klarzukommen dass
wir an den norddeutschen küsten
flüssiggasterminals bauen dass wir die
pipelines bauen die dazu notwendig sind
damit ihr unabhängig von russland gas
nach deutschland importieren können wir
haben die kapazitäten aus den
niederlanden aus belgien jetzt aus
frankreich erweitert weil wir ein
problem mit macht und uns vorbereitet
haben über das sie damals noch nicht
einmal gesprochen haben
und in einem tempo zudem keine cdu
geführte regierung in diesem land je
fähig gewesen ist werden wir es schaffen
im januar werden die ersten dieser
terminals ihren betrieb aufnehmen das
ist eine gemeinschaftsleistung in
deutschland
und während cdu geführt der minister es
überhaupt kein problem fahren
ministerien ist überhaupt kein problem
fanden dass die speicher für gas in
diesem land leer waren im letzten jahr
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass sich das
ändert mit gesetzen und regelungen die
wir auf den weg gebracht haben
sie hatten noch nicht mehr in der
opposition ist der fertiggebracht das
eigene versäumnisse als problem der
neuen regierung unterzuschieben wir
hatten es schon gelöst bevor sie
überhaupt mitbekommen haben das war
einst war das ist die wahrheit oder
gerechnet
und wären wir mit den speicher zu gast
in deutschland so unverantwortlich
vorgegangen wie das die zu vorher
verantwortlichen der vorher
verantwortliche minister und die
regierung gehabt haben dann würde ich
ihnen ausdrücklich sagen hätten wir
jetzt nicht 85% speicherkapazität
sondern quasi nicht so wie im letzten
jahr das ist der unterschied zwischen
der union und den verteidiger das land
gehört
sie haben noch immer gefordert dass wir
dafür sorgen sollen dass die speicher
voll sind und da haben wir die gesetze
schon gemacht sie könnten auch mal sagen
dass sie das eine beeindruckende
leistung finden hernals
und da gibt es noch ein thema auf das
sie gar nicht gekommen sind über das sie
nie geredet haben wo sie nichts
gefordert haben als es darauf angekommen
wäre wir haben gesetze auf den weg
gebracht die dafür sorgen dass
kohlekraftwerke in diesem land in dem
betrieb gehen können dass sie genutzt
werden können dass sie nicht
abgeschaltet werden alles das haben wir
auf den weg gebracht das war eine
notwendige leistung mit großer
geschwindigkeit und großem tempo die wir
hier auf den weg gebracht haben
und sogar solche fragen wie diese hier
nebenbei angesprochen sind längst dabei
gelöst zu werden wie zb das natürlich
die kohlekraftwerke loslegen können auch
wenn sie nicht genügend gelagert haben
und auch die tatsache ist die biomasse
anlagen dass die solaranlagen alle aus
alles an kraft zeigen können was sie
brauchen das haben wir gesetzlich alles
vorbereitet sie brauchen nur noch
zugucken wie das geschieht es ist schon
erledigt bevor sie es ausgesprochen
haben
und wir haben ein gesetz gemacht fuel
switch die gesetzlichen regelungen dafür
geschaffen dass überall in deutschland
betriebe und unternehmen entscheidungen
treffen können dass sie nicht auf gast
zurückgreifen müssen sondern andere
anlagen betreiben können damit wir
gemeinsam gas sparen und durch diesen
winter kommt auch das haben diese schon
gemacht sie haben es noch nicht mal
gefordert
ja und ich weiß es ist für sie sehr
enttäuschend weil sie sich so sehr auf
das thema der kernenergie konzentriert
haben aber das was wir jetzt vorbereiten
ist dass die möglichkeit besteht dass
wir die kernkraft anlagen die
atomanlagen im süden deutschlands
betreiben können damit es niemals an
strom lange in deutschland gibt auch
wenn das in diesem winter im januar
februar und märz notwendig ist das ist
vorbereitet und das ist die grundlage
dafür dass das ganze was sie sich schon
vor zwei wochen als rhetorisches konzept
erlegt import überlegt haben hier heute
gescheitert ist
sie reden einfach am thema und an den
problemen dieses landes vorbei und das
ist wirklich ein ganz ganz großes
problem und wenn andere die probleme
lösen die sie noch nicht mal erkannt
haben dann reden sie auch noch drum rum
im übrigen ist das jetzt eine situation
in der wir anders als vor einem jahr
weil wir soviel eingespeichert haben
weil wir all diese vorkehrungen
getroffen haben weil wir all diese
entscheidung getroffen haben in einer
situation sind in der wir sank um können
wir kommen wohl durch trotz aller
anspannung durch diesen winter mit den
vorbereitungen die wir gemacht haben das
hätte niemand vor drei monaten vor vier
monaten vor fünf monaten vor am beginn
des jahres sagen können und weil wir so
früh angefangen haben als noch gar nicht
ein so großes problem problembewusstsein
in deutschland da war darum sind wir
jetzt in der lage dass wir tapfer und
mutig in diesem winter hinein gehen
können dass unser land das überstehen
wird das ist die sache die wir gemacht
haben
insofern sind sie also schief gewickelt
wenn ich das mal so sagen dass sie haben
einfach an dem thema vorbei geredet dass
unser land wirklich umtreibt und wir
sind jetzt dabei die nächsten dinge zu
tun die notwendig sind damit die
bürgerinnen und bürger und unsere
wirtschaft durch diese situation kommen
wir haben bereits zwei entlastungspaket
verschlossen und jetzt kommt das dritte
weil wir ganz konkret gucken was zu tun
ist wie wir es schaffen können dass die
bürgerinnen bürger dass die unternehmen
dieses landes dass der mittelstand die
großen unternehmen die möglichkeiten
haben die sie brauchen damit sie weiter
produzieren können damit die
arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben damit man
sich das leben leisten kann und ich
finde es ist richtig dass wir das getan
haben wir haben zwei erste pakete von
knapp 30 milliarden euro bereits
beschlossen jetzt kommt 1 noch einmal
dazu dass knapp 65 milliarden euro
umfasst alles zusammen eine ziemlich
große summe und das dient dazu dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger durch diese zeit
kommen dass die unternehmen kommen durch
die zeit kommen und dass die
arbeitsplätze gesichert werden you never
walk alone das ist das motto dieser
regierung
ich bin sicher unser land über sich
heraus wachsen wir werden zusammenhalten
wir werden die herausforderung bestehen
vor dem wir uns jetzt befinden und wir
werden die probleme lösen die wir
miteinander haben weil wir niemanden
alleine lassen mit seinen
herausforderungen und dazu dienen auch
all die entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben zb die entscheidung zu sagen dass
jetzt wo in diesem monat die
energiepreis prämie gezahlt wird das
anders als möglichkeit bei den
arbeitnehmenden arbeitnehmern ankommt
haben wir auch entschieden dass es auch
für rentnerinnen und rentner und
studenten gelten soll das ist eine
entlastung in einer schwierigen zeit wo
alles teurer wird richtig dass wir das
tun hat
wir machen eine bürgergeld reformen die
dafür sorgt dass diejenigen die sehr
wenig geld haben auch durch diese zeit
kommen können dass sie unterstützt
werden aber vor allem sorgen wir dafür
dass teil diejenigen die diesem land
arbeiten oder als renten um rentner
einmal gearbeitet haben all die
unterstützung bekommen die sie brauchen
damit sie das finanzieren können was an
teuren lebenshaltungskosten bei ihnen
ankommt und das ist geschehen mit den
dingen die ich schon genannt habe aber
zb auch mit der größten wohngeldreform
seit der einführung des wohngelds in
diesem land zwei millionen berechtigte
stadt 700.000 das wird unglaublich viele
familien in diesem land besser stellen
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern mit
geringen einkommen und rentnern rente
eine richtige eine notwendige
entscheidung
zb indem wir dafür sorgen dass familien
unterstützt werden das kindergeld wird
erhöht die schritte die für das nächste
und das übernächste jahr anfallen machen
ziehen wir zusammen machen das in ein
schritt mit 18 euro wir sorgen dafür
dass der kinderzuschlag verbesserte da
geht es für manche familien um ein paar
hundert euro im jahr die sie mehr zur
verfügung haben eine richtige eine
notwendige entscheidung in dieser zeit
wir sorgen dafür dass diejenigen die
wenig verdienen und den wir mit
steuerentlastungen wenig helfen können
eine entlastung bekommen indem wir die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge für die sie
zahlen müssen absenken und dafür sorgen
dass bis zu einem einkommen von 2000
euro die progressionszone bei den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen fortgesetzt
wird das sind über 1,3 milliarden euro
netto entlastung für diejenigen die am
wenigsten in diesem land verdienen und
von steuersenkung sonst nichts hätten
nicht zu vergessen dass gerade jetzt
wenn das stattfindet zum ersten oktober
der mindestlohn auf 12 euro angehoben
wird in einer solchen zeit eine dringend
notwendige entscheidung für die wir uns
lange eingesetzt haben meine damen und
herren
und wir entlasten die bürgerinnen und
bürger in dem wir steuersenkung
beschließen in großem umfang in dem wir
auf die inflation reagieren und
dementsprechend das flächendeckend
organisieren mit der anhebung des
freibetrages mit den steuer senken damit
verbunden sind übrigens verknüpft mit
lauter maßnahmen die wir jetzt auf den
weg bringen oder schon auf den weg
gebracht haben wie zb dass die
rentenbeiträge abgezogen werden können
vom steuereinkommen voller höhe das sind
die beiden nächsten jahre zusammen fünf
milliarden euro entlastung für
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmer eine
richtige entscheidung und eine
notwendige entscheidung
und wir haben dafür gesorgt dass die
arbeitnehmerpauschale angehoben wird das
wird weiter im nächsten jahr gelten dass
die pendlerpauschale angehoben ist auch
das sind dinge die alle da zusammen
beitragen dass wir eine möglichkeit
haben durch diese zeit zu kommen und für
uns ist auch wichtig dass wir uns nicht
nur auf uns alleine beschränken ich habe
schon vor der sommerpause gesprochen in
der konzertierten aktion mit
unternehmensvertretern mit
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber mit den
gewerkschaften mit der wissenschaft der
bundesbank über die frage was wir machen
können wenn wir uns unterhalten und
deshalb ist die konzertierte aktion eine
notwendige antwort des zusammenhalts auf
diese krise und wir werden deren
entscheidungen und die aktivitäten der
unternehmen unterstützen indem wir sagen
wenn jetzt wegen dieser preis schreibung
der höheren energiekosten die
sozialpartner die gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber vereinbaren das ist höhere
sonderzahlungen gibt dann werden wir bis
zu 3000 euro steuer- und abgabenfrei
ermöglichen das ist eine konkrete
botschaft des zusammenhalts in
deutschland und eine botschaft der tat
partnerschaft
sind also wir haben sehr viel gemacht um
die drängenden probleme vieler
bürgerinnen und bürger in den griff zu
bekommen und wir werden das auch weiter
tun weil das notwendig ist die maßnahmen
die wir gemacht haben haben wir auch
große erfahrung mit sich gebracht viele
haben hier sehr skeptisch diskutiert ich
erinnere mich an einige äußerungen aus
der union wenn ich das richtig erinnern
dass wir das neun euro ticket einführen
und nicht sage ausdrücklich das war eine
große sache die skeptiker hatten nicht
recht und deshalb wird es eine
fortsetzung geben für eine lösung die
das möglich macht bundesweit
abonnierbare digital buchbare tickets zu
haben die zu einem vertretbaren tarif
überall in deutschland die nutzung des
nahverkehrs möglich machen eine gute
entscheidung aus der krise gewachsen
aber für viel viel längere zeit sinnvoll
was dann natürlich dazu kommt ist dass
wir die herausforderung bewältigen
müssen die mit den steigenden
energiekosten verbunden sind wir haben
also als sie noch nicht daran gedacht
hatten schon das problem gelöst wie
sichern wir die energieversorgung
deutschlands
was nicht möglich gewesen ist denn die
cdu/csu ist die partei die die komplette
verantwortung dafür hat dass deutschland
ausstiegs entscheidung getroffen hat aus
der kohle und aus der atomenergie aber
die niemals die kraft hatte in
irgendetwas einzusteigen sie waren
unfähig den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien erweitert führen sie haben ab
der kämpfe geführt gegen jede einzelne
windkraftanlage und jeder ab der kampf
der letzten jahre schadet unserem land
noch heute das kann sie
dafür haben sie auch immer sehr
freizügig gemogelt die letzte mogelei
watt vor der letzten bundestagswahl
unions geführtes wirtschaftsministerium
mit absicht wurde die wahrheit dass wir
bis zum ende dieses jahrzehnt ein
anstieg der stromproduktion von 600
terawatt auf 800 terawatt brauchen
verschwiegen und als der bundestag in
die sommerpause kam da wurde es
veröffentlicht das ist und
verantwortliche cdu-politik wir uns in
die jetzige situation gebracht
naja herbergs
hören sie genau zu
als ich vorgeschlagen hat in der
bundesregierung wir sollten doch
flüssiggas cremans bauen an den
norddeutschen kürzen wir sollten doch
flüssiggas terminals an den deutschen
küsten bauen und wir dazu einen brief
entwickelt hatten hat ein mitglied der
bundesregierung vermutlich cdu dass dem
spiegel gesteckt damit sich alle darüber
aufregen dass wir das tun hätten wir es
man getan will ich ausdrücklich dazu
sagen dann müssen wir jetzt nicht mit
diesem tempo das machen
und eine partei die bis heute fast jede
windkraftanlage persönlich bekämpft hat
überhaupt nichts zu tun mit der frage
wie lösen gerät die energieversorgungs
probleme der zukunft das ist die
wahrheit wir aber haben in diesem jahr
schon mehrere gesetze auf den weg
gebracht und werden noch weitere auf den
weg fragen die dazu führen dass wir in
dem notwendigen schnellen tempo den
ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
zustande kriegen offshore wind onshore
in solaranlagen ein starkes
leistungsfähiges netz und
selbstverständlich alles was dazu gehört
und werden auch schon ein paar probleme
weniger wenn es nicht der heroische
kampf der csu und in bayern gewesen wäre
dafür zu sorgen dass noch nicht alle
übertragungsnetz leitungen in den süden
deutschlands errichtet worden sind dass
das was sie gemacht haben
dafür tragen sie die verantwortung
es war unverantwortlich das zu tun und
es ist gut dass sie in der opposition
sind damit wir die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes hinkriegen
damit wir wettbewerbsfähig bleiben und
uns nicht mehr vor den problemen dieses
landes drücken
ja wir müssen unabhängig werden von den
gasimporten aus russland und das werden
wir in großer geschwindigkeit tun in
wilhelmshaven in stade in brunsbüttel in
lubmin werden neue terminals entstehen
wir haben an den westeuropäischen kosten
mit unseren freunden gesprochen in den
niederlanden in belgien dass sie die
terminals ausbauen und die
leitungskapazität mit frankreich das das
erste mal gast zu uns liefern wird wir
haben probleme gelöst da hatten sie noch
gar nicht mitgekriegt dass die überhaupt
existieren und das ist das was wir jetzt
zustande gebracht haben mit den
terminals am morgen und mit denen in
deut besser europäischen küsten werden
wir eine sichere energieversorgung für
deutschland gewährleisten
was aber natürlich auch dazu gehört und
das will ich dazu sagen ist dass wir
jetzt mit denen nachdem wir die
versorgungssicherheit zum großen thema
gemacht haben auch das problem mit den
preisen in den griff nehmen und deshalb
ist es richtig dass wir sagen wir werden
das mag design auf dem strommarkt
verändern wir werden nicht zulassen dass
die hohen preise die für strom aus
gaskraftwerken heute gezahlt werden dazu
führen dass es extra große profite gibt
für jemand der das mit windkraft mit
wasserkraft mit solarenergie der das
macht mit braunkohle und steinkohle oder
nuklearenergie sondern wir werden diese
zusätzlichen gewinne abschöpfen um die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten mit
einer strompreis bremse das ist die
richtige antwort und wir haben sie
gegeben
und natürlich werden wir uns mit der
frage der gaspreise auseinandersetzen
müssen und der hohen kohlepreise und
ölpreise die ja alle davon auch mit
berührt sind wir haben uns darum
gekümmert dass das möglich ist wir
sorgen jetzt dafür dass wir zusammen mit
europa diskutieren die kriegen wir das
thema im griff denn anders als beim
strommarkt gibt es ja darum dass sie ihr
importieren aus ländern die die preise
anderswo bestimmt aber wir müssen
trotzdem hinkriegen dass sich das ändert
das erste was wir hinkriegen müssen ist
das wenn wir das geschafft haben worum
wir uns jetzt im eiltempo kümmern und
sich vorher niemand gekümmert hat
nämlich dass wir jederzeit gast aus
aller welt importieren können mit den
ganzen terminals über die ich eben
gesprochen hat dass wir den
weltmarktpreis nur bezahlen müssen und
nicht die höheren preise die durch diese
fehlenden import strukturen heute
aufgerufen werden aber wenn wir das
geschafft haben dann geht es jetzt auch
darum dass wir den weg beschreiten wie
wir diese preise nach unten kriegen das
werden wir mit unseren freunden in
europa und mit allen hier in deutschland
erörtern denn das ist eine sache die wir
nicht auf sich beruhen lassen die preise
für die energielieferung müssen runter
die bürgern und bürger müssen die preise
auch bezahlen können und wir werden
dafür sorgen
wir erleben eine zeitenwende ich habe
das hier im deutschen bundestag gesagt
das ist der russische angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine der die europäische
friedens- und sicherheitsrat nung
zertrümmert hat der unverändert eine
riesige große bedrohung ist für frieden
und sicherheit in europa denn das war ja
die verständigung der letzten jahrzehnte
dass das nicht passiert dass man mit
gewalt grenzen verschiebt und etwas
anderes ist es nicht als imperialismus
was der russische präsident versucht
sich nicht mich einfach teile des
nachbar territoriums oder das ganze
anzueignen und man darf ihn auch nicht
missverstehen er hat das ja alles
öffentlich gesagt in aufsätzen
geschrieben es gibt überhaupt nichts an
der frage zu deutschland was seine
absicht ist deshalb unterstützen wir die
ukraine mit unseren verbündeten wir tun
es schon sehr lange und wir tun es sehr
effektiv auch mit den notwendigen
schweren waffen mit artillerie mit
möglichkeiten zur luftverteidigung und
all dem was wir auf den weg gebracht
haben das sind die modernsten waffen die
exakt jetzt in dem gefecht im osten der
ukraine gebraucht werden wir werden das
auch weiter tun das ist unsere
verpflichtung so lange wie es notwendig
ist
und es ist sehr umfangreich was wir
getan haben aber eins unterscheidet uns
von ihnen ganz offensichtlich sie haben
es heute bekannt wir werden keine
alleingänge machen wir werden keine
deutschen alleingänge machen das wäre
ein schwerer schwerer
unverantwortlicher fehler und ich sage
ausdrücklich an die union gerichtet wer
für alleingänge plädiert sollte dieses
land nicht regieren
und was wir tun was wir tun ist
eingebettet in die gemeinsamen handlung
mit unseren verbündeten insbesondere den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und wer
nicht verstehen will wer genau begreifen
will was die regierung leitet der
braucht nur den aufsatz von präsident
biden in der new york times durch lesen
wo exakt das erzählt hat was ich ihnen
hier auch sagen erstens wir werden als
verbündete handeln wir werden keine
entscheidung treffen die dazu führen
dass der krieg den russland
verbrecherischer weise gegen die ukraine
führt zu einer eskalation eines krieges
führt zwischen nato und russland aber
wir werden das notwendige tun und genau
entlang dieser linie denkt eingebettet
in das bündnis in mit unseren freunden
in aller welt unterstützen wir die
ukraine und werden es so lange machen
wie es notwendig ist
das sind ernste zeiten es sind ernste
zeiten in denen der zusammenhalt in der
gesellschaft von allergrößter bedeutung
ist und deshalb sind es auch zeiten in
denen sich immer wieder beweisen muss zu
was wir miteinander fähig sind ich bin
überzeugt wir sind ein land das diesen
zusammenhalt auch hat das in der lage
ist die schwierige zeit zu bewältigen in
der wir uns jetzt befinden und es auch
in der lage ist den weg in die zukunft
zu beschreiten das haben wir gemacht mit
weitreichenden entscheidungen in diesem
jahr weit reichende entscheidung als sie
in den letzten jahrzehnten über alle
zeit hinweg verteilt worden sind in
einem einzigen jahr das ist die aufgabe
der regierung und das werden wir auch
weiter zu tun schön
dass bundeskanzler wie man ihn selten
ein lebt leider kann man fast sagen wie
schon bei der letzten debatte im
bundestag wenn olaf scholz angegriffen
wird kann er auch entsprechend lebhaft
oder hier er wies alle vorwürfe zurück
seine regierung habe von anfang an
vorgesorgt um die energiesicherheit zu
garantieren
habe dafür im letzten jahr nicht
vorgesorgt habe die gasspeicher nicht
gefüllt den ausbau der erneuerbaren
verhindert wir kommen wohl durch durch
diesen winter das ist seine botschaft
heute niemand werde alleingelassen
betonte olaf scholz zum wiederholten mal
es folgt eine zweite die
fraktionsvorsitzende der afd nächste
rednerin für die fdp fraktion dr alice
weide
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
damen und herren gott sei dank ist die
nabelschau zwischen herrn merz und dem
bundeskanzler vorbei sie haben damit
eindeutig gezeigt dass ihnen die
ernsthaftigkeit fehlt für die lage in
der sich unser land befindet
deutschland steuert in den schwersten
sturm seit bestehen der bundesrepublik
millionen existenzen stehen auf dem
spiel
zahllosen bürgern droht die formung der
mittelständischen wirtschaft der
zusammenbruch den staatsfinanzen
dauerhafte zerrüttung und auf der brücke
der stadt schiffs steht der kapitän der
titanic
will von eisbergen nichts wissen und
beschwichtigt die leute mit hohlen
durchsagen das haben wir ja gerade
gehört mit so einer besatzung kann die
reise nur im desaster enden ein
bundeskanzler der in ein steuer und
finanzskandal verwickelt ist und sicher
nichts erinnern kann ein
wirtschaftsminister der die bürger
schröpft um lobbyisten und
energiekonzern zu geben aber von
ökonomischen und technologischen
zusammenhängen überhaupt keine ahnung
haben nicht mal weiß was insolvenzen
sind
hier ist gestern abend in einer talkshow
ja von sich gegeben hat ein
finanzminister der schulden systematisch
verschleiert eine innenministerin die
auf dem linken auge blind ist beim
islamismus wegschaut und den
verfassungsschutz als etablierten schutz
missbraucht ein justizminister der
willkürlich grundrechte einschränkt ein
von einem virus besessener
gesundheitsminister der laufen wird und
unsinniges von sich gibt eine
verteidigungsministerin die
militärischen gerät offenbar nur dann
etwas anfangen kann wenn es um urlaubs
vehikel taugt und schließlich eine grüne
außenministerin die verspricht an der
seite der ukraine zu stehen gleichgültig
wie hart und verheerend die
sanktionspolitik für die eigenen bürger
wird egal was meine deutschen wähler
denken das ist offenbar das motto dieser
bundesregierung
ihr amtseid schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden wir zum meineid
ideologische fantasien und arrogantes
festhalten an fehlentscheidungen sind
ihnen wichtiger die verbohrte festhalten
abschalten der letzten kernkraftwerke
ist dafür der beste beleg sie ruinieren
dieses land wirtschaftlich um die
irrationalen dogmen der grünen klientel
und lobbyisten zu bedienen sie haben
allen grund einen heißen herbst und
winter zu fürchten denn die bürger haben
jedes recht herr merz gegen eine solche
regierung und gegen eine solche politik
auf die straße zu gehen natürlich haben
sie
galoppierende inflation
eine sterbende währung und
explodierender energiepreise bedeuten
für millionen bürger mehr als nur ein
bisschen frieren wie im gönnerhaft von
oben mitgeteilt wird auch für haushalte
der mittelschicht geht das an die
existenz sie können ihre rechnungen
nicht mehr bezahlen ihre rücklagen
renten und versorgungsansprüche werden
rasant entwertet ihnen droht verarmung
und abhängigkeit
von öffentlicher fürsorge die aber
endlich ist wie wir heute bereits sehen
in der schöpfung der steuerzahler bis in
die existenzvernichtung
viele die heute noch ihre familien
ernähren können werden ihre arbeit
verlieren reihenweise stellen
mittelständische unternehmen bereits
jetzt die produktion ein weil sie die
energierechnung nicht mehr stemmen
können becker und dünger fabriken
porzellan und glas hersteller gießereien
und aluminiumwerke
inflation und energiekrise zerstören den
unternehmerischen mittelstand und die
bürgerliche mittelschicht die
entlastungs paket hat für unseren
mittelstand und für unsere mittelschicht
nichts übrig sie versprechen zuschüsse
die die arbeitende bevölkerung selbst
bezahlen muss
sie verteilen geld das sie den bürgern
vorher mehrfach weggenommen haben und
stellen das als wohltat da
60 prozent der deutschen haushalte
müssen ihre gesamten einkünfte nach
steuern
für die lebenshaltung einsätzen zum
sparen bleibt nichts mehr essen
sparkassen studie so müssen nicht mit
dem kopf schütteln hier bei den grünen
sondern sie müssen einfach die studien
lesen dass sie das sich wollen noch
keine ahnung davon haben das beweisen
sie mit ihrer politik wenn das das grün
wirtschaftswunder ist
das im wahlkampf angekündigt wurde dann
danke für nichts und ihre scheinheiligen
appelle und durchhalteparolen an die
bürger sich einzuschränken ob hut zu
bringen und kalt zu duschen waschlappen
zu benutzen für die ukraine für die
energiewende oder für ein klima das
können sie sich sparen das wollen die
leute nicht hören um in dieser krise zu
bestehen muss unser laden die ursachen
von inflationen energiekrise angehen
davon habe ich von ihnen nichts gehört
in dieser aussprache inflation und
energiepreise ziehen schon seit mehr als
einem jahr an bei der entwicklung denn
das direkte resultat einer schlechten
jahrzehntelangen politik die energie
krise ist hausgemacht sie ist direkte
folge der energiewende die mit ihrem
abschaltbaren und two renten steuern und
abgaben strom künstlich verknappten
verteuert hat nur uns in eine einseitige
abhängigkeit von russischem erdgas
geführt hat das ist doch die wahrheit
die grünen wollen doch nicht so tun es
ist ihr angestrebtes ziel die
energiekosten in die höhe zu treiben und
damit die nachfrage einzuschränken da
viel haben sie jetzt ja damit erreicht
die inflation ist zudem das resultat der
maßlosen geldschöpfung null zinspolitik
der ezb zur finanzierung hoch
verschuldeter und aufgeblähter
staatshaushalte zweieinhalb jahre locker
und politik und eine kopflose
sanktionspolitik als reaktion auf den
ukraine krieg haben das kartenhaus zum
einsturz gebracht die konsequenzen
liegen auf der hand
nur ihre regierung wie sie nicht sehen
und die entsprechenden maßnahmen nicht
ergreifen erstens die steuern müssen
runter senkung der energiesteuern der
mehrwert und der einkommenssteuer
streichen
der co2 abgabe und eine echte streichung
und abschaffung des unsäglichen eg
zweitens die ezb muss in die pflicht
genommen werden ihren auftrag zu
erfüllen und für stabiles geld zu sorgen
drittens die staatsausgaben müssen auf
das wesentliche konzentriert werden
innere und äußere sicherheit
gewährleistung von rechtsstaatlichkeit
und öffentliche ordnung schluss mit
ideologie politik klientel versorgung
und geld verteilen in alle welt
illegale migration und einwanderung in
die sozialsysteme liegen schon wieder
über dem niveau von 2005 10 aber sie
öffnen die letzten schleusen und senden
neue migrations signale durch fast schon
bedingungslose einbürgerung fünftens das
energieangebot muss ausgeweitet werden
wir müssen energie erzeugung und
energieimporte and
moralisieren das heißt im klartext
schluss mit der resourcen vergeuden für
windkraft und photovoltaik sie sich
krisenfest wohl nicht versorgungssicher
windkraft trägt nur einen bruchteil der
installierten leistung zur versorgung
bei kernkraft nahezu 100 prozent setzen
normalisierung der gasimporte aus
russland und wenn erforderlich öffnung
von nord stream zwar natürlich
laufzeitverlängerung für die noch
aktiven kernkraftwerke reaktivierung der
zu der stillgelegten und natürlich dem
bau neuer kernkraftwerke
wir brauchen die kernkraft für eine
saubere sichere und bezahlbare energie
und schon dass die cdu das jetzt auch
familie zu begreifen scheint er märz
ihre partei die seit 16 jahren nach der
grün-roten pfeife tanz haben wir diese
misere überhaupt erst zu verdanken die
energiewende ins nichts ist resultat
dieser politik und 16 jahre merkel und
die fortsetzung der energiewende und der
missbrauch der krise um sie noch zu
forcieren
münden im sicheren ruin die bürger
dieses landes die aber in der
bevölkerung und der mittelstand
industrie brauchen freiheit und luft zum
atmen und nicht immer neue vorschriften
und gänge lang und schon gar nicht
brauchen sie auch noch in dieser lage
das muss man sich mal vorstellen ein
neues infektionsschutzgesetz in den
meisten ländern wird das corona virus
bereits wie ein saisonales grippe virus
behandelt ohne massnahmen chaos masten
zwang und nötigung das gesetz dass sie
morgen zur abstimmung stellen wollen
macht den ausnahmezustand zur
dauereinrichtung und die grundrechts
einschränkung zum regelfall schämen sich
und das ist ein armutszeugnis für die
fdp dass sie sich dafür hergibt da nützt
auch ein kubicki netz und aber
vielleicht und das ist so meine
vermutung wollen sie ja jetzt schon eine
handhabe sich sichern um demonstration
gegen ihre politik durch die hintertüre
desinfektions schutzes zu verbieten frau
feser das ja gar keine gelegt weitaus um
regierungskritische demonstration in die
rechtsradikalismus ecke zu stellen was
für eine bankrotterklärung für diese
regierung welche die demonstrations- und
meinungsfreiheit mit füßen tritt
beenden sie die deutsche geisterfahrt in
der korona energie und migrationspolitik
kommen sie zurück auf den boden der
tatsachen
korrigieren sie ihre falsche politik
statt immer neue fehlentscheidungen zu
treffen ja dass das das steht ihm gut zu
gesicht der spott der grün merken sie
sich das die leute werden sich das
merken wie sie hier reagieren wie dieses
land hier geradewegs an die wand fährt
durch ihre politik und will sie nicht
willens oder fähig sind ihren kurs zu
ändern dann treten sie bitte ab denn das
wäre das beste entlastungspaket für
unser land
das war alice weidl mit heftigen
vorwürfen ideologische fantasien
irrationale dogmen würden diese
regierung prägen inflation steigende
energiepreise all das rechtfertige das
bürger auf die straße gehen die
regierung soll endlich die ursachen der
krise angehen alles weidl fordert eine
senkung der energiesteuern und den
weiterbetrieb der atommeiler es folgt
mit der hasselmann die
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren erst mal möchte ich
mich bedanken frau präsidentin für
unsere gedenkstunde hier und ihre worte
für michael gorbatschow vielen dank
dafür ich glaube es war wichtig und
notwendig dieses signal an diesem tag
auch zu senden und damit die
parlamentsdebatte zu eröffnen und meine
damen und herren ja wir streiten und wir
ring heute im parlament zwischen den
demokratischen kräften
über die frage was sind die richtigen
maßnahmen was sind die lösungen sehen
die einen versäumnisse und die anderen
sehen wir tun was aber eins eint uns an
diesem morgen
das nämlich klar ist dass wir als
demokratinnen und demokraten
zusammenstehen gegen die rattenfänger
von rechts und wenn es
eines beweises bedurft heute der beitrag
von alles weiden und und das video das
gerade durch social media läuft da
wünscht sich der milch ein teil der
fraktion der afg dass es noch hertha
kommt dass es noch schlimmer wird dass
die krise sich manifestiert damit sie
als ard mit ihren lügen ihrer propaganda
und ihrer menschenfeindlichkeit eine
chance für das anwachsen der ard sehen
und meine damen und herren egal woher
märz herr scholz oder britta haßelmann
stehen das werden die demokratischen
kräfte im land verhindern und darüber
bin ich
meine damen und herren wir führen hier
eine inhaltliche und der kontroversen
debatte in krisenzeiten und der märz ich
wünsche mir dass ein blick auf die
wirklichkeit der ist zwingend notwendig
den sollten sie sich aufstellen
wer meine damen und herren hat uns in
diese zementierte abhängigkeit geführt
ja der krieg putins auf die ukraine
heute nach
196 tagen ist die situation für die
menschen so schrecklich so dramatisch so
zerstörerisch dass wir uns feststehen
muss dass die solidarität
uneingeschränkt geht unsere
unterstützung humanitärer
wirtschaftlich und auch mit waffen die
sie dringend brauchen dass wir die als
deutscher bundestag garantieren und die
ukraine wissen hier seid nicht allein
gelassen euch nicht im stich das ist das
signal aber wie hat und das ist die
krise aus der viele andere krisen
erwachsen ich denke oft an das leid die
zerstörung für die menschen in der
ukraine
aber wer hat uns in diese zementierte
abhängigkeit von russland geführt von
fossilen energien das sagt doch gerade
eine rot-grüne ich glaube ich spinne
leute der bilder besitzen sie eigentlich
sie haben 16 jahre regiert und wir
wissen dass sie es waren die den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien blockiert
haben wo sie nur konnten wir haben alles
getan auf bundesebene
und auf länder ebene da wo sie
regierungsmehrheiten hatten um den
ausbau der erneuerbaren um
energieeffizienz energieeinsparung um
moderne technologien die uns daran
hindern weiterhin die energie in die
atmosphäre zu schleudern co2 auszustoßen
um dagegen etwas zu tun das ist ihre
verantwortung 16 jahre unionsgeführte
regierung und tat sie das wo allgemein
nie glauben wollen helfe ich ihm
gedankenstütze wer hat eigentlich dafür
gesorgt dass der gasspeicher 20 15 20 15
an gazprom ging das war ihr
bundeswirtschaftsminister
es war die verantwortung von altmaier
die uns eingeführt habe meine damen und
herren und wir hat bis zuletzt die
letzte bundesregierung hat bis zuletzt
an nordstream zweit festgehalten auch
diese große viele entscheidung ist eine
entscheidung die sie gemeinsam zu
verantworten haben während wir davor
gewarnt haben auch daran erinnert sich
heute wirklich nicht gerne jemand und
die rufe aus ihrer fraktion für ein gas
embargo soll ich ihnen die
presseberichte zeigen vermehrt sie
standen doch in der ersten reihe dabei
ich bin froh dass wir das nicht getan
haben wo wären wir denn heute in der
krisenbewältigung
wo wären wir heute was müssen wir den
menschen zumuten wenn wir uns auf dieses
auf diese vielen entscheidungen kollege
hängen gelassen die kollegen assen
lassen keine zäune und ihre ideologische
debatten führung in hinblick auf atom
die ist doch entlarvend meine damen und
herren da sagt hier einer mit großen
augen nein wir sind auch nicht für die
verlängerung von atomlaufzeiten kommt im
fünften satz aber so drei bis vier jahre
oder vielleicht bis zum ende der
energiekrise herr merz wissen sie
eigentlich was das heißt das heißt die
verlängerung der atomenergie das heißt
den ausstieg vom ausstieg den hatten sie
doch schon mal hinter sich denn sie
wissen doch dass mit nein ganz es fakt
und sie sollten sich damit mal
beschäftigen denn drei bis vier jahre
halten die brennstäbe überhaupt nicht
sie müssten neue brille stelle gezogen
und damit sind wir ein ausstieg aus dem
ausstieg und der ist uns schon mal
einmal teuer gekommen gerade wegen ihnen
und ihrer viele entscheidung in der
regierungszeit 29 bis 23 10 meine damen
und herren auf eine debatte wird so
fakten frei geführt wie diese der
stresstest der
stresstest der polizei zeigt ganz
eindeutig er rechtfertigt keine
verlängerung der atomenergie und das ist
gut so meine damen und herren es handelt
sich um eine hochrisikotechnologie
wir haben den auftrag und zwar
gesetzlich und auch durch das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit auf den weg
gegeben dass wir uns um die gefahren für
die bürgerinnen und bürger sorgen machen
müssen und was nicht geht ist dass sie
weiterhin lamentieren und polemisieren
und solche primitiven formeln wie drei
+3 +3 von anti steuer aus bayern auch
noch ernsthaft in die debatten hier
einziehen 4 andreas scheuer aus der csu
ist für dass wir drei neue
kernkraftwerke bauen das soll ein
beitrag zur krisenbewältigung im hier
und jetzt sein wissen sie wie lange ein
bau eines atomkraftwerkes dauert
offenbar nicht aber bis bayern hat sich
dass die schon gesprochen der mann hat
ja auch nur verantwortung dafür
irgendwelche dinge in die welt zu pusten
aber sonst nichts auf die endlager frage
gibt es keine antwort trage nicht von
cdu und csu
außerdem satz nur nicht in bayern meine
damen und herren und deshalb lassen sie
uns zu den fakten zurückkommen wir holen
jetzt nach was jahrelang versäumt wurde
dass nämlich die priorität auf dem
ausbau der erneuerbaren der
energieeinsparung der energieeffizienz
liegen und daher reicht es auch mit
ihren polemisieren gegen robert habe
denn der allen voran an der spitze hat
gerade verdammt viel zu tun und leistet
viele und ich rate unter spricht doch
aus jeder pore
aus jeder pore spricht doch der neid
wenn ich höre dass manche sagen es täte
manchen gut
ich finde es täte manchen von ihnen gut
erst zu denken dann zu sprechen
meine damen und herren wir
haben jetzt drei entlastungs paket auf
den weg gebracht und das ist doch
wirklich wichtig und notwendig denn wir
können doch nicht sagen wie weit wir
jetzt sind wie sich die krise weiter
entwickeln wird es wird viele menschen
sprechen in unserem land das wissen wir
und wir sind längst nicht am ende
mit diesen unterstützungs paketen wir
sind in den krisenmodus ja und wir
werden vieles tun müssen sozial abfedern
in erneuerbare energien investieren und
die ökologische und soziale
transformation der wirtschaft weiter
begleiten und werde heute so tut als
wäre die eine maßnahme das richtige und
damit wäre alles getan streut den
menschen sand in die augen wir können
doch nur das ausgeben wir nehmen eure
sorgen und ängste war wir wissen viele
menschen haben angst vor abstiegen und
vor armut und wir finden dass ab und ob
wir und ob wir in zwei monaten mehr tun
müssen weitere dinge auf den weg bringen
müssen das wird sich zeigen das weiß
heute noch niemand weil noch niemand
weiß wohin die krise noch geht und wie
tief sie greifen wird und deshalb ist es
wichtig das signal auszusenden
wir bauen die soziale ökologische
transformation der ausbau der
erneuerbaren mit kraft wir machen uns
unabhängig was jahrelang versäumt wurde
in sachen energieversorgung wir
versuchen gemeinsam mit wirtschaft
handwerk und dem mittelstand
die ja ja ja wir tun alles dafür in
dieser krise zu stabilisieren und darum
geht es im moment und wir machen jetzt
in dieser woche die
haushaltsplanberatungen die auch ein
klares signal geben auf die frage wohin
wollen wir investieren dann geht es auch
nicht nur um die nationalen fragen es
geht auch um die internationale
verantwortung die wir haben klimaschutz
umwelt natur
entwicklungszusammenarbeit humanitäre
hilfe für die krise nein das ist
notwendig und hier ist jede
kraftanstrengung notwendig findet nach
pakistan sehen wenn wir die jetzt zur
entwicklung in diesem sommer in europa
ansehen auch hier bei uns dann wissen
wir was sie uns hinterlassen haben
nämlich lauter baustellen die wir jetzt
im hinblick auf die bekämpfung der krise
der klimakrise angehen müssen und sie
zeigen sich in so einer dramatik dass
wir auch im rahmen des haushaltes hier
akzente setzen müssen die unsere
internationale und nationale
verantwortung deutlich unter das ist
wichtig und gleichzeitig mit dem dritten
entlastungspaket ein signal gesendet
dass wir menschen hier im land die wenig
haben dass wir die zielgenau
unterstützen wollen und gehen sie nicht
so darüber hinweg ja ich höre kritik
allgemein am entlastungspaket wo sind
sie denn mit ihrer verantwortung beim
thema bürgergeld bei den menschen die
wenig haben wir machen gerade die größte
regelsatzerhöhung die es seit einführung
von hartz tier gibt und das ist der
erste schritt wir machen gleichzeitig
das wohngeld den heizkostenzuschuss die
fragen von energiepreis pauschale alles
wichtige soziale alles wichtige soziale
abfederung sie werden dazu beitragen
dass sich not lindert natürlich bleibt
es dabei dass viele menschen in einer
kritischen situation sind und wir werden
immer wieder überlegen ob die maßnahmen
die die auf den weg bringen reichen oder
ob wir noch nachsteuern müssen wie zb
beim kleinen handwerk ob den bäckereien
fleischereien oder der kulturszene
wir müssen doch gemeinsam als parlament
das signal aussenden wir lassen euch
nicht im stich wir überlegen uns immer
wieder wo können wir ansetzen was können
wir tun und dass es verantwortliches
handeln meine damen und herren
und weil ich gerade über die
angesprochen habe die wenig haben
ich finde es infam wie markus söder
auf kosten von beifall im bierzelt beim
gillamoos über menschen gesprochen hat
die wenig geld haben und den
grundsicherung leben mein eindruck ist
sie kennen diese lebenswirklichkeit von
menschen die arm sind überhaupt nicht
ansonsten ja ich glaube schon ich habe
lange genug als sozialarbeiterin
gearbeitet
ich glaube dass markus söder damit ein
zeichen ausgesendet hat ihm ist jedes
mittel recht zur parteipolitischen
profilierung
profilierung und sei es auf dem rücken
von menschen die arm sind die wenig
haben und das finde ich in form dass
sowas wird
mit sowas der wahlkampf eingeläutet wird
demnächst jahr vor sich haben ich finde
das
unzulässig aber vielleicht muss es jeder
für sich verantworten was er da tut aber
die abwertung von menschen ist ein
mittel den wir uns gemeinsam wirklich
sagen sollte das ist nicht unser ding
und das tun wir nicht alle waren ich
glaube wir stehen gerade in wirklich
schwierigen zeiten niemand wird sagen
durch die ein oder andere maßnahme ist
die krise vorbei wir versuchen alles wir
geben alles krisenbewältigung zu machen
den ausbau der erneuerbaren
voranzubringen und uns unabhängig zu
machen und wir nehmen unsere
internationale verantwortung wahr weil
wir wissen nur gemeinsam sind wir stark
in dieser zeit die zeitenwende sozial
und nachhaltig gestalten darum geht es
jetzt meine damen und herren vielen dank
das war britta haßelmann von linken und
den rattenfänger seien die abgeordneten
der afg alle demokratischen parteien
stimmen im kampf gegen die asg zusammen
betonte licht musik heute was wenn man
kritisierte zudem heftig die union die
deutschland beim gas in die abhängigkeit
von russland gebracht habe den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien verhindert
habe und natürlich verteidigte sie den
ausstieg aus der atomenergie nächste
rednerin ist nun am iran mohammed ali
die fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
[Applaus]
säge präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen millionen menschen in
deutschland haben angst sie haben angst
vor dem brief des energieversorgers weil
die preise verdoppelt oder sogar
verdreifacht
sie haben angst um ihren arbeitsplatz
immer mehr unternehmen sind von der
insolvenz bedroht oder sind bereits drin
und die die ein paar ersparnisse haben
die haben angst dass dieses kleine
polster von der inflation einfach
aufgefressen wird und all die vielen
millionen die keine ersparnisse haben
die wissen überhaupt nicht mehr wie sie
über diesen winter kommen soll die
aktuellen preissteigerungen die fressen
im schnitt ein ganzes monatseinkommen
pro jahr auf und das hat dramatische
folgen für die direkt betroffenen
menschen aber auch für die gesamte
deutsche wirtschaft dieser
kaufkraftverlust der wirkt jetzt schon
verheerend und herr scholz sie haben
jetzt hier in ihrer rede
sich einen guten teil der zeit an
friedrich merz abgearbeitet um zu zeigen
weil hier der tolle hecht im teich ist
ich meine das erfreut vielleicht ihre
fanbase hier im raum aber es ist der
laden in diesem land wirklich nicht
angemessen wo die macht
und wir stolz
die werden sie werden nicht müde zu
behaupten dass keiner allein gelassen
würde leider stimmt das nicht und das
wissen die menschen auch und es wird
eben nicht dadurch besser dass sich da
den worten an der berühmten fußballhymne
bedienen und immer wieder jung never
walk alone erklären es stimmt nicht denn
was sie hier als sogenanntes
entlastungspaket vorliegen ich muss es
so sagen es ist einfach eine frechheit
und bevor ich da ins detail gehe nur
einmal die groben zahlen angucken das
neue entlastungspaket das soll ein
volumen von 65 milliarden euro haben
alle drei entlastungs pakete sollen ein
gesamtvolumen von 96 milliarden euro
haben ob die zahlen stimmen ist übrigens
zweifelhaft aber selbst wenn sie stimmt
ist das immer noch weniger geld als sie
über nacht für das sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr einfach aus dem ärmel
gezogen haben das waren rund 100
milliarden euro dafür soll die
schuldenbremse ausgesetzt für die
unterstützung der bevölkerung wird sie
es nicht und während die koalition sich
über die 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr über nacht einig war und über
die entlastungen für die bevölkerung
gestritten und gerungen wochenlang damit
man bloß nicht aus versehen jemanden
bedenkt der ist ihrer meinung nach nicht
verdient hätte und auch hier mit
bestenfalls wieder gekleckert es wird
eben nicht geklotzt dabei wäre das
dringend notwendig sie wollten sich ja
nicht mal dazu durchringen das maßen die
nachweise die inflation gebremst haben
der tank rabatt das neue euro ticket
dass die verlängert werden in meinem
wahlkreis in niedersachsen kostet das
regional ticket jetzt wieder 190 euro
statt 9 euro im monat ich meinte die
pendler geben ihnen recht wenn sie den
sagen
es soll jetzt eine nachfolgeregelung
kommen ziemlich kompliziert und vor
allem soll sie über die länder
mitfinanziert werden sie wissen aber
dass viele länder das finanziell
überhaupt nicht stimmen können das doch
eine luftnummer dass die wahrheit
und ich meine die stellen sich die
ernsthaft hin und versuchen das als
großen sozialen wurf zu verkaufen dass
sie den rentnerinnen und rentnern nach
massivem druck von uns von der linken
von sozialverbänden von der
öffentlichkeit endlich auch das mickrige
energie geld von 300 euro zukommen
lassen wollen studierende kriegen sogar
nur 200 euro beides reicht überhaupt
nicht aus und die tatsächlichen teuro
abzufangen das doch einfach nur ein witz
kolleginnen und kollegen kommen wir mal
zum kindergeld
18 euro erhöhung 18 euro erhöhung der
wahnsinn ich meine dass ihnen das nicht
peinlich im koalitionsvertrag steht die
kindergrundsicherung drin die kommt
nicht stattdessen kommt diese
lächerliche erhöhung sie beißen das in
die entlastungs bäckerei damit sie
behaupten können die kinder wäre auch
was drin ich mein wissen sie eigentlich
wie viel teurer
schulhefte stifte und andere notwendige
dinge geworden sind jetzt zum
schulanfang ist das für viele familien
ein echtes problem sich das leisten zu
können das ist die wahrheit die
lebensmittelpreise sind im letzten jahr
im schnitt um 20 prozent gestiegen die
kindergelderhöhung macht mich mal zehn
prozent aus und das heißt das heißt dass
die eltern wie das kindergeld brauchen
wir den monat zu kommen das sie jetzt
bei sich sparen müssen um ihre kinder
noch ernähren zu können das ist bereits
jetzt die realität in vielen familien
was meinen sie denn wie gut das bei
denen ankommt wenn sie immer wieder
sagen you never walk alone und kommen
wir jetzt zum bürger gilt ich meine das
klingt vielleicht besser aber es ist
leider nichts anderes als hartz4 hat
vier für arme das leider wörtlich
gemeint die erhöhung von 50 euro ist
nicht mal der inflationsausgleich nicht
mal ansatzweise das ist in wirklichkeit
überhaupt keine erhöhung die menschen in
grundsicherung werden weiter von ihrer
politik abgehängt das ist die wahrheit
und was sagen sie all den vielen die
seit jahren gezwungen sind bei der tafel
an zu stehen und die jetzt nicht mal
mehr dort genug lebensmittel kriegen
weil die tafeln auch unter druck sind
stellen sie sich daneben und so haben
sie den schon erwogen ich glaube nicht
dass betrifft inzwischen schon zwei
millionen menschen unserem land die
müssen zur tafel gehen die tendenz ist
steigt laut dem forschungsinstitut für
wärmeschutz in münchen müssen menschen
in schlecht gedämmten wohnungen bei den
aktuellen preisen bereits und
energiekosten von rund 4500 euro pro
jahr rechnen letztes jahr waren das noch
1800 die kosten haben sich mehr als
verdoppelt in einfamilienhäusern
auch wenn sie gedämmt sind steigen die
energiekosten von 2800 auf
7200 euro pro jahr diese preis explosion
die muss gestoppt werden aber leider tun
sie das nicht und ihre angekündigte
strompreis bremse ist leider jetzt schon
eine luftnummer einmal weil die teuerung
eben nicht nur den strombereich
betreffen sondern den gesamten
energiebereich aber vor allem weil diese
strompreis bremse nur dann kommen soll
wenn sie gegenfinanziert wird über eine
über gewinn steuer die wiederum davon
abhängt dass die eu-kommission dafür
grünes licht gibt andere länder haben
das längst ein gefühl dann über gewinnt
steuerung verstecken sie sich hinter
brüssel die man sie sagen erst wenn es
in brüssel nicht klappt dann wird eine
nationale regelung erwogen
ich meine sie tun ja so als hätte die
lösung dieser probleme noch ewig zeit
nein die menschen brauchen jetzt die
unterstützung
und darum wären auch direktzahlungen
jetzt wichtig die wirklich wirkung
entfalten wir fordern mindestens 125
euro pro monat also 1500 euro pro jahr
für jeden haushalt mit kleinem und
mittleren einkommen denn der
kaufkraftverlust ist vergeben immer mehr
betriebe bäckereien friseure die die
preise aufgrund der steigenden kosten
erhöhen mussten die sehen dass ihnen die
kunden wegbrechen weil sie einfach nicht
mehr das geld haben da hin zu tun der
chef des ifo institutes clemens fuest
der sagte über die maßnahmen der
bundesregierung dass sie die rezession
nicht verhindert werden in diesem winter
ein vernichtendes urteil
das institut für deutsche wirtschaft
rechnet damit dass es bei den steigenden
preisen
300.000 zusätzliche arbeitslose im jahr
2023 geben wird ich meine haben wir den
mitarbeitern den job center schon durch
gestellt was ihren verzweifelten
menschen von ihnen ausrichten sollen
never walk alone man sagen sie dem trost
irgendwann kommt vielleicht mal eine
strompreis bremse wenn brüssel mitspielt
das reicht nicht kolleginnen und
kollegen dieser energie mag der muss
reguliert werden das ist die wahrheit
ich meine wenn man einmal gesehen hat
dass der markt ist nicht richtet dann
doch jetzt wir brauchen eine
funktionierende staatliche preisaufsicht
und wir brauchen eben auch einen preis
paypal für die gesamte energie für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher das ist
auch wenn
in frankreich oder ein preis regel
eingeführt da übernimmt der staat die
differenz zwischen den festgelegten
verbrauchspreis und den tatsächlichen
marktpreis warum geht das nicht bei uns
und ja ich weiß ja ich weiß ja die
antwort dafür ist angeblich kein geld da
denn es gibt ja die schuldenbremse das
lieblingskind von herrn lindner und ich
möchte ihnen mal sagen wenn sie trotz
dieser historischen krise lieber an
ihrem fetisch schuldenbremse festhalten
wollen anstatt zu verhindern dass immer
größere teil der bevölkerung in die
armut getrieben werden dann ist das
einfach nur verantwortungslos wenn wir
diese historischen krise die bevölkerung
in ihrer breite trifft nicht einmal
darüber nachdenken die vermögenssteuer
wieder einzuführen die spd und grüne das
noch im wahlprogramm hatten wenn es auch
das einfach nur verantwortungslos ich
meine wenn nicht jetzt wann dann bitte
in dieser lage an der von allen menschen
solidarität erwartet würden den
angeblich alle den gürtel enger
schnallen sollen nicht dafür zu sorgen
dass diejenigen mit dem weitesten gürtel
den das überhaupt nicht weh tun würde
wenn sie ein bisschen enger schnallen
würden die teilweise ihr vermögen der
krise noch sagt vermehren konnten die
multi millionäre die milliardäre wenn
sie jetzt nicht dafür sorgen dass die
sich zumindest ein stück weit angemessen
an den krisenkosten beteiligen dann
fällt mir wirklich absolut nichts mehr
dazu eine inakzeptable es ist unsozial
das nicht zu tun
natürlich darf man bei alldem nicht
vergessen dass die preis explosion durch
den russischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine verursacht worden ist dieser
angriffskrieg der kann nicht akzeptiert
werden man musste darauf reagieren wir
als linke unterstützen die sanktionen
gegen putins machtapparat gegen die
mächtige oligarchen gegen die russische
rüstungsindustrie
was wir aber kritisieren das sind
sanktionen die hauptsächlich die
russische bevölkerung treffen und die in
deutschland in europa im globalen süden
mehr schaden anrichten als bei denen den
man eigentlich schaden sollten nämlich
putins kriegsmaschinen wir stellen aber
fest die kriegsmaschinerie rollt
unbeeindruckt von europäischen
sanktionen leider weiter in ländern des
globalen südens gibt es bereits
ernsthafte versorgungslücken weil sie
beim weltweiten preiskampf um das erdgas
eben nicht mithalten können und auch
hier bei uns drohen weitere extreme
preissteigerungen ebenfalls
versorgungslücken beides gut zum
wegbrechen ganzer industriezweige führen
das darf man nicht geschehen lassen
kolleginnen kollegen
darum
fordern wir von der bundesregierung
es muss alles unternommen werden um auf
diplomatischen wege einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand zu erreichen damit
friedensverhandlungen beginnen können
dieser krieg muss so schnell wie möglich
ändern und zweitens
sie müssen mit russland in verhandlungen
über die gaslieferungen treten und die
versorgungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
das erwartet die bevölkerung zu recht
ich nehme sie beim wort herr scholz die
haben gesagt die sanktionen dürfen
europa nicht härter treffen als russland
bitte handeln sie ihr sprechen dank
das war die fraktionsvorsitzende der
linken sie kritisierte dass bei den
entlastungen nicht geklappt sondern nur
gekleckert werden anders als beim
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr die
regierung lasse viele zu viele bürger
alleine jetzt sein direktzahlung wichtig
zum beispiel 125 euro für haushalte mit
niedrigen einkommen pro monat sowie ein
preis deckel für strom und eine
vermögensabgabe
es folgt christian tod der
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
vielen dank frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen kollegen wie einige von
ihnen auch hatte ich am sonntag die
gelegenheit mit dem ukrainischen
ministerpräsidenten dennis schmidt zu
sprechen und er hat mir noch einmal
geschildert dass in sehr eindringlichen
worten was zurzeit das ergebnis dieses
angriffskrieges russlands auf die
ukraine ist und vor mohammed ali man
müsse mit russland jetzt mal in
verhandlungen treten man müsste mit
denen mal reden
wissen sie was alle telefone sind immer
offen aber die wahrheit ist russland
will genau das was gerade passiert auch
mit dem menschen der ukraine das ist
kein versehen russischer politik es ist
absicht russische politik dass menschen
in der ukraine sterben meine damen und
herren das ist dass durch diesen typ das
ist dass durch die taktischen schritt
vom montag
und wir spüren die finanziellen
auswirkungen ich komme darauf gleich zu
sprechen während in der ukraine jeden
tag menschen sterben ihr zuhause
verlieren oder das land verlassen müssen
ich habe
ministerpräsident michael wie viele von
ihnen auch in diesen gesprächen die
solidarität auch der bundesrepublik
deutschland auf einmal zum ausdruck
gebracht und zur einordnung dessen was
passiert russland wladimir putin führt
einen physischen krieg gegen die
menschen in der ukraine aber er führt
eben auch ein krieg mit nahrungsmitteln
und mit energie gegen die gesamte welt
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass der
westen weiter zusammen steht meine damen
und herren deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass die nato derzeit gestärkt wird
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir auch
mit unseren transatlantischen freunden
in diesen tagen auch was das thema
waffenlieferung betrifft auch was das
thema finanzielle unterstützung der
ukraine betrifft zusammenstehen der
zusammenhalt der westlichen
staatengemeinschaft ist die ganze
zentraler antworten in diesen
schwierigen tagen für die gesamte welt
ihre kolleginnen kollegen
und ich will als erstes auf das thema
was in vielen reden heute morgen schon
natürlich unterstrichen worden ist
nämlich die energieversorgung zu
sprechen kommen die oberste prämisse in
den nächsten monaten ist die preise an
den energiemärkten müssen sinken diese
preise meine damen und herren das muss
man sehr klar aussprechen sind für
niemanden derzeit zu tragen nicht für
die privaten haushalte in deutschland
nicht für die unternehmen nicht nur für
die energieunternehmen in der
energieintensiven unternehmen nicht zu
tragen sondern selbst der einzelhändler
um die ecke kann sich 20 fach höhere
stromkosten schlicht und einfach nicht
leisten aktuell ist es etwa das
zehnfache aber selbst das führt
natürlich zu katastrophalen entwicklung
im gerade in mittelständischen
unternehmen meinen damen und herren ja
das ist die ausgangssituation und herr
kollege merz ich fand ihre aussage sehr
interessant weil wir ja auch darüber
sprechen müssen um für die zukunft zu
lernen was in den letzten jahren
passiert ist sie haben gesagt diese
regierung trägt nicht allein die
verantwortung für die abhängigkeit
russlands
wissen sie was diese bundesregierung
stellt sich der verantwortung die
verantwortung in jedem fall trägt diese
bundesregierung und nicht aber sie ist
gewählt um jetzt verantwortung zu
übernehmen und das tun wir liebe
kollegen kollegen
es ist die abhängigkeit russlands vom
erdgas und das ist da keine leichten
antworten gibt haben die reden heute
morgen deutlich gesagt herr merz ich
will auch daran erinnert was sie am
zehnten märz diesen jahres gesagt haben
sie waren der erste politiker aus der
unionsfraktion der gesagt hat man muss
die
erdgaslieferung die energielieferung
ausmustern sofort einstellen das ist
dass der märz was sie am 10 märz gesagt
hat das ist das was sie an zu schmerzen
niemand ist glücklich über diese
abhängigkeit sie ist eine ökonomische
katastrophe und auch geopolitisch zu uns
eine herausforderung aber mehr
zubereiten könnte zu dieser einfachen
antworten gibt es nicht weder das
einstellen der erdgaslieferung noch
jetzt irgendwelche deckel ich komme
darauf gleich zu sprechen sind die
perfekte antwort diese bundesregierung
ich wiederhole es stellt sich dieser
verantwortung die vorgängerregierung
verursacht haben liebe kollegen im
kollegen
und jetzt will ich sagen was wir tun sie
mir die gasanlage viel gesprochen wir
werden jetzt die mehrwertsteuer auf
diese gas umlage noch einmal senken und
die zielgerichtete
ausrichten meine damen und herren denn
es ist natürlich für viele kunden für
viele unternehmen geradezu ein
überraschen sie wussten bisher gar nicht
von wem der lieferant das erdgas bezogen
hat ist es doch niemand verantwortlich
zu machen kein unternehmen kann
mittelständler dass russisches erdgas
über seinen versorger bezogen hat und
jetzt in dramatische preissteigerungen
kommt deswegen brauchen wir dort eine
umlage das ist das thema gasmarkt aber
ich komme auf den strommarkt zu sprechen
der hier auch viel besprochen worden ist
meine damen und herren es
ist kein geheimnis dass auch in der
frage der weiternutzung der kernenergie
meine parteien auffassung dazu hat auch
was die drei bestehenden kernkraftwerke
betrifft aber genauso richtig ist es
dass wir jetzt an diesen strommarkt
etwas tun und deswegen ist die
entscheidung des koalitionsausschusses
sich für eine strompreis bremse nicht
nur einzusetzen auf europäischer ebene
sondern gegebenenfalls
national auf diesen schritt zu gehen das
bestehende system der eeg umlage zu
nutzen damit die strompreise in
deutschland für alle menschen vor allem
unternehmen nach unten gehen das ist die
richtige antwort in dieser krise auch
wenn sie ordnungspolitisch nicht leicht
ist das sage ich ganz offen aber es ist
die richtige antwort in dieser krise
dass die strompreise so runter gehen
meine damen und herren und endlich
richtig als signal märkte und an die
unternehmen in deutschland
und herr merz was schlagen sie denn vor
denn die burg problembeschreibung auch
die abhängigkeit von russland da sind
wir einer meinung aber was haben sie
denn vorgeschlagen für den strommarkt
haben sie sehr konkret vorgeschlagen
denn sie waren ja verzug spitze ich habe
mich gefragt beim lesen des papiers ob
es bisweilen auch mit der die lüfter
oben zusammenhängt sie haben
vorgeschlagen für den sprung lag das
spanische modell sie sagen braucht ein
gaspreis deckel an der stellung das
erdgas soll aus dem strommarkt
herausgenommen werden wir wissen
übrigens gar wir sehen gerade was in
spanien passiert in spanien finanzieren
die spanischen steuerzahlerin
steuerzahler gerade den stromexport nach
frankreich meine damen und herren um den
strom an der stelle billiger zu machen
das kann doch kein modell für
deutschland sein dass unsere
steuerzahler dann am ende des tages
subventionierten strom bezahlen und das
über den bundeshaushalt erst das ist
keine option für deutschland die
strompreis bremse ist die richtige
antwort und deswegen hat die
bundesregierung diese auch getroffen
und zweitens seien gasmarkt beim gas
markt schlagen sie in ihrem papier von
der zugspitze vor einen gaspreis deckel
wissen sie werden gerade verteidigt hat
vor mohammed ali von der linkspartei
also sie sagen am besten soll das über
den bundeshaushalt geregelt werden der
bundeshaushalt wird dann die differenz
dieses deckels im vergleich zum
marktpreis tragen meine damen und herren
mit ihren vorschlägen suggerieren sie
eine ist nämlich dass die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler die
gestiegenen energiepreise decken können
ich sage in aller kleid ja wie an diesen
märkten veränderungen vornehmen aber ein
spurt zu weiter zu der staat die
gemeinschaft der steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler der kann diese
energiepreise nicht einfach schultern
das würde die staatliche gemeinschaft in
deutschland überfordern diese wahrheit
muss man aussprechen alles andere herrn
merz ist eine illusion ich will das
deutlich an dieser stelle sagen die
kollegen
[Applaus]
und ich habe schon gesagt putin hat
diese krise ausgelöst aber
wir wissen doch alle dass der reformstau
in diesem land angesichts dieser krise
wie unter einem brennglas deutlich wird
meine damen und herren deutschland ist
bei der digitalisierung hinterher wir
sind beim klimaschutz hinterher wir
haben viel geld dafür ausgegeben den
letzten jahrzehnten aber wenig erreicht
am ende des tages die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der bundesrepublik
deutschland ist gefährdet wegen zu
starker abhängigkeiten es muss mal
gesagt werden wir sind in deutschland in
den letzten zwei jahrzehnten aus vielen
dingen ausgestiegen meine damen und
herren aus vielen technologien
ausgestiegen aber wir hätten zum
gleichen zeitpunkt mit aller macht auch
in neue technologien einsteigen müssen
meine damen und herren der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie ist nicht in dem
maße vorangekommen aber vor allen dingen
der ausbau das eher konventionelle
energiekette ersetzen können meine damen
und herren wo war denn der einsatz
seiner zeit für den ausbau der
stromnetze wo war denn der einsatz
seiner zeit für die grundlastfähigkeit
auch erneuerbaren energien das muss doch
die zukunft zwar ein co2 neutrales aber
gleichzeitig trag verfall die
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
meine damen und herren da sind die
fehler gemacht worden für sie waren
erneuerbare ein feigenblatt und
landschaftsbild vor uns sind die
erneuerbaren die wirtschaftliche
grundlage in der zukunft der
bundesrepublik deutschland liebe
kolleginnen kollegen das auch einmal
deutlich
und ich komme zu dem neben den dingen
die wir an den märkten tun müssen ich
habe das unterstrichen ich komme zum
entlastungspaket zum dritten
entlastungspaket denen das der
koalitionsausschuss am wochenende
erarbeitet hat als
erstes der inflationsausgleich für die
arbeiten menschen in diesem land steht
an oberster stelle in diesem paket und
das richtigerweise und auch da muss ich
noch einmal auf das eingehen was sie
lieber herr kollege merz in ihrer rede
gerade gesagt haben sie haben gerade
richtung der bundesregierung behauptet
das stünde ja eben gesetz das würde
sozusagen automatisch also wir hätten
gesetzestext aufgeschrieben ich würde
ganz gerne eine wette eingehen ich
möchte den paragrafen
einkommensteuergesetz gerne sehen herr
merz wo das was sie behauptet haben drin
steht die wahrheit ist doch die union
hatte nie den mut den abbau der kalten
progression in der einkommensteuer
gesetze schreiben die wahrheit ist das
was hier behauptet ist schlicht falsch
ja andere europäische länder machen das
deutschland macht es bedauerlicherweise
bisher nicht und weil das nicht der fall
ist wird dieser ampel koalition die hart
arbeitende mitte in deutschland
entlasten ein ganz wichtiges signal des
koalitionsausschusses liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und
wir werden natürlich auch um diejenigen
kümmern die nicht im arbeitsleben sind
um die rentnerinnen und rentner um die
menschen in ausbildung um die studieren
und studierende mit einer weiteren
energie pauschalen wir werden das
kindergeld erhöhen wir werden die home
office pauschalen im steuerrecht
entfristen wir senken die umsatzsteuer
auf gas ich erwähnte ist von wir setzen
den zinkpreis die erhöhung zum ersten
januar aus damit die menschen und
unternehmen nicht zusätzlich belastet
werden die steuerliche absetzbarkeit der
rentenbeiträge das thema
doppelbesteuerung von unionsgeführten
bundesregierung nie gelöst wird diese
bundesregierung lösen meine damen und
herren und es wird ein bundesweites
nahverkehrsticket geben und da ist ja
manche bundesländer in deutschland gibt
in denen die union entweder den
ministerpräsidenten stellt oder mit in
der bundesregierung ist habe ich
folgenden appell für sie anstatt hier
hin und her zu reden unterstützen sie
den verkehrsminister volker wissing bei
diesem revolutionären vorhaben ein
digitales deutschland ticken bundesweit
anzubieten da müssen die länder jetzt
über ihren schatten springen wäre eine
revolution für unseren öffentlichen
personennahverkehr genau das zu tun
meine damen und herren
also es sind die familien der mitte aber
auch diejenigen die es schwer haben die
von diesen dritten entlastungspaket
entsprechend profitieren meine damen und
herren jetzt habe ich mir auch an der
stelle noch mal angeschaut was auf der
zugspitze so passiert ist und was in den
letzten tagen gesagt worden ist ernährt
sagt ja das waren richtige schritte ich
anerkenne dass sie sagen auch entlastung
kalte progression und manches mehr sind
richtige schritte den wir als
regierungskoalition gehen ich habe mir
angeschaut was sie fordern sie haben es
eben hier nochmal wiederholt für das
untere drittel der einkommen eine
pauschale von 1000 euro das macht etwa
16 milliarden euro für den
bundeshaushalt für jedes kind einmal
noch mal 1000 euro das sind etwa fünf
milliarden für den bundeshaushalt und
der vorgeschlagene gaspreis decke meine
damen und herren der wird etwa 38
milliarden euro für den bundeshaushalt
machen ich will mich ich will mich nicht
auf den euro festlegen meine damen und
herren ich habe das aber mal zusammen
was sie offensichtlich nicht getan haben
wir reden hier über 50 milliarden euro
zusätzliche belastung für den etat für
den bundeshaushalt meine damen und
herren ich frage wer soll das bezahlen
sie fordern einen gaspreis deckel
anstelle einer umlage ich frage wer soll
das bezahlen
sie fordern eine subventionierung der
gasverstromung als unionsfraktion
anstelle der strompreis bremse ich frage
wer soll das bezahlen meine damen und
herren der gaspreis decke wo sie
eigentlich sind mit der linkspartei soll
aus dem haushalt finanziert werden aber
die sind wenigstens so ehrlich und sagen
dass sie die schuldenbremse abschaffen
wollen meine damen und herren die
stabilität unseres landes ist in diesen
tagen gefragt und alles das will ich zum
schluss sagen darf auf gar keinen fall
passieren indem wir den bundeshaushalt
selber überfordern indem wir eine
expansive geldpolitik und ausgabepolitik
am ende des tages machen es darf auf gar
keinen fall passieren dass wir die
inflation durch den haushalt zusätzlich
anreiz und frau präsidentin ich komme
jetzt zum schluss und will noch eine
anmerkung machen in aller kürze und da
habe ich mir angeschaut was sie noch
vorschlagen sie schlagen vor eine
abwrackprämie für haushaltsgeräte das
klingt ja erst mal nett aber ich frage
mich
welcher ökonom in der gesamten welt ist
zurzeit auf der empfehlung dass er sagt
wir müssten in zeiten der inflation
nachfrage politik zu machen anstatt
angebotspolitik ich habe vorhin erwähnt
was die bundesregierung alles macht aber
mit verlaub herr merz ökonomisch sinn
gerade auf der facebook wo nur mitlaufen
sie das falsch in zeiten der inflation
in zeiten der inflation muss man doch
angebotspolitik machen planungs
beschleunigung der digital strategie die
giga betze die gigabit netze die bildung
investitionen in die
verkehrsinfrastruktur mehr
freihandelsabkommen und mehr
einwanderung in den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt meinen damen und herren
ökonomisch und ich hätte fast nicht
geglaubt dass ich das jemals aussprechen
werden ökonomisch sind so manche
jungsozialisten in der spd zurzeit markt
unterwegs als die unionsfraktion im
deutschen bundestag ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
so wir blenden uns hier aus dieser
debatte aus und schalten noch einmal zu
meiner kollegin andrea maurer die
debatte vor ort im bundestag beobachtet
hat andrea das war heute eine besonders
lebhafte und kontroverse debatte nach
den streitereien in der koalition der
letzten wochen und tage welchen eindruck
machte heute die ampel
nun wir haben hier heute einen
ungewohnte kämpferischen kanzler erlebt
kämpferische in richtung opposition
kämpferisch auch als botschaft an ein
für unser viertes land kämpferisch aber
auch nach innen also in richtung
koalitionspartner denn einvernehmlich so
wie sich das der kanzler wünscht ist
diese koalition gerade beim thema
laufzeitverlängerung und atomkraft nicht
die fdp möchte ja eine
laufzeitverlängerung und hält da das
letzte wort auch noch nicht für
gesprochen
die grünen beharren auf dem plan nur
zwei atomkraftwerke in notreserve zu
lassen bis früher also der plan von
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck beide
parteien haben hier im parlament auch
nochmal ihre unterschiedliche position
deutlich gemacht der kanzler hat nun
gesagt die stromversorgung im winter sei
gesichert wir werden durch diesen winter
kommen hat er gesagt was auch als
versuch eines machtworts nach innen zu
deuten ist einig war sich die ampel hier
heute vor allem darin dass auch die
union nicht aus der verantwortung für
eine energiekrise in diesem land
gelassen werden kann die ampel hätte das
land schlecht vorbereitet übernommen
ja herzlichen dank andrea das war's für
heute ich bedanke mich für ihr interesse
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen tag und
sage tschüss bis zum nächsten mal